[Musique]
bon bon bon en bas
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission qui n'est pour
rien dans la libération de maurice papon
avec nous ce soir
thierry mariani le député qui revient de
bagdad a chjama de bouchaoui le faire du
fond ces inculpés pour le 11 septembre
francis huster
michèle bernier olivier besancenot
jean pierre gaillard inès de la
fressange philippe sollers elisabeth
quin pierre assouline ali cévennes jean
luc lemoine et notre comme life death
consacré ce soir aux connexions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais avant on va regarder ce qui s'est
passé de mieux la semaine dernière ça
s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé
[Musique]
magnéto serge sarran pas mégalo comme ça
de haranguer d'aidé foule de plusieurs
milliers de personnes avec la voix
booster avec son image sur des écrans
géants c'est totalement ses noeuds c'est
une drogue dure mais en même temps comme
c'est le métier que j'avais choisi ça
devrait le seul truc que je sais faire
mais aborde beaucoup de pognon
j'ai du mal à renoncer à leurs côtés
deux ans de travail 500 candidates au
départ 1 500 ce qui fait mille nichons
voilà c'est un techno parade de jack
lang s'est encore plus chiant que la
fête des mères c'est absolument
insupportable
si vous étiez président jack lang
combien y aurait-il de gay pride par an
peut-être qu'il y en aurait plus aucune
puisque finalement nous aurions
profondément transformé les honneurs la
vitrine une norme gay pride
[Rires]
la bei se vêtir et en plein vol pendant
deux jours par une cinquantaine de mal
et d'ailleurs le mal et il tirait il
laisse les couilles et la [ __ ] sur le
truc d'ailleurs tiré immer tire son coup
en plein vol comme un vulgaire stewarts
un mec décider qui a décidé de donner sa
vie vous une armée entière
cette guerre ne peut pas être gagnée on
peut pas les américains ont compris
qu'ils se faisait descendre les deux
tours du world trade center
avec douze mecs décidé quatre heures il
ya des parents qui éduquent leurs
enfants en leur disant si tu te fais
péter la gueule en tuant d'autres
personnes tu seras un héros
elle ne me dites pas que ça peut pas
arriver parce que c'est ce qui se passe
ce gosse de 17 ans il y a des gens qui
donnent de l'argent à sa famille il y a
des gens qui lui donne la ceinture de
bombes
ces gens là ont des noms ce sont des
organisations certaines basé en arabie
saoudite
ce sont des états la syrie l'irak se
sont une partie des dirigeants ce
palestinien
c'est l'autorité palestinienne elle-même
qui a détourné le fric de l'aide
humanitaire le fric de la communauté
européenne pour fanatisés des ghosts
je baise les pieds de tous les
pacifistes du monde entier a compris à
commencer par les israéliens et les
américains parce que faut avoir une
sacrée paire de couilles pour être
pacifiste en israël et je leur baise les
pieds je leur dis merci d'exister
voilà c'était tout le monde va parler je
puisse est passé de mieux la semaine
j'accueille mme atlan thierry mariani
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thierry mariani bonsoir moi ça tout le
monde parle de vous puisque samedi
dernier en compagnie de deux autres
députés eric diard député des bouches du
rhône et didier julia député de
seine-et-marne tous trois ump
vous avez discrètement pris l'avion pour
bagdad dont vous êtes rentré mardi
dernier après avoir inspecté des sites
irakiens et ce face à la colère de
chirac de raffarin
de villepin est balladur alors pourquoi
ce voyage
pourquoi parce que je crois qu'on est au
niveau du monde à la veille peut-être
d'une immense bêtise et on voulait tous
les trois se rendre sur place dialoguer
avec les responsables politiques
irakiens pour leur faire partager notre
position qui en plus seul du président
de la république qui était qu'il fallait
absolument que ce pays accepte le retour
des observateurs de l'onu pour
désamorcer la crise c'est ce qu'on a
fait pendant deux jours ce qui a été un
peu mouvementée mais après tout qui est
une extraordinaire expérience mais en
allant en irak est ce que vous croyez
que vous êtes dans votre rôle de député
du vaucluse après tout parce que même si
raffarin a dit qu' il fallait les sur
terrain il pensait peut-être pas l'irak
oui mais tu allais à bord n'est pas
député du vaucluse si on prend la
constitution les députés de la france
excusez-moi chacune de nos nous sommes
577 à l'assemblée chacun de nous
représenter une parcelle ça fait un peu
pompiers de dire ça mais la souveraineté
nationale non je pense qu'elle est au
moment où il faut être député du
vaucluse
mais je suis aussi député de la france
et je pense que mon pays n'a pas à
s'engager peut-être dans un conflit
avant d'avoir essayé toutes les
possibilités pour trouver la paix c'est
la deuxième fois que je vais en irak
j'étais déjà allé en novembre dernier
je partage pas du tout les comment dire
l'option du régime politique irakien
j'ai pas vous expliquer que c'est une
démocratie
personne ne le croit parce que je sais
simplement c'est que c'est un pays
peut-être pas très démocratique comme il
en existe des 50 bonne cinquantaine dans
le monde voire une bonne centaine alors
déclare pas pour autant la guerre sauf
si on veut mettre la main sur leur
pétrole on est allés tous les trois on a
discuté avec les responsables politiques
de ce pays on essaie de leur faire
partager la position de la france à
position du président de la république
la position du gouvernement qui consiste
à dire vous devez absolument accepter le
retour des inspecteurs pour éviter la
guerre maintenant facile chirac avait eu
envie que vous alliez en irak pour
expliquer la position du gouvernement
français
et vous lui aurait demandé oui mais vous
savez que
c'est mon troisième mandat à l'assemblée
il ya presque les formules de style à
chaque début de mandat où on dit il faut
que les députés soient indépendantes du
pouvoir etc
je crois que depuis montesquieu dans ce
pays on a inventé ce qui s'appelait la
séparation des pouvoirs
moi je suis membre du pouvoir législatif
le président de la république que je
respecte et que je soutiens et membre du
pouvoir exécutif
peut-être que par moments le pouvoir
législatif peut encore exister sans
demander forcément un billet de sortie
alors qu'ils étaient au courant vraiment
on décolle pas pour bagdad commandes
écoles pour avignon
ouais il faut quand même être un peu
sérieux je veux dire l'irak est un pays
sûr sous embargo
c'est à dire comme une partie de la
presse a souligné cette semaine avant de
décoller il faut quand même que l'avion
s'est signalé il faut trois tampons
modeste qui s'appelle ministère des
affaires étrangères ministère de la
défense ministère du budget pour
décoller donc le décollage n'était pas
très discret il faut demander une fois
demandé à l'onu il faut que la france
transmettre le plan de vol à l'onu les
l'onu avait accepté
oui mais l'onu de façon c'est un vol il
y avait pas d'armes c'est un vol pas si
mal que donc bien sûr qu'il va accepter
donc y avait des gens au courant au
ministère des affaires étrangères avait
bien sûr des gens qui étaient au courant
initialiser des affaires étrangères je
précise que moi même j'avais eu l'âme
des fonctionnaires du ministère des
affaires étrangères qui était
parfaitement au courant qui nous avait
dit ça nous était pas forcément
conseillé
alors s'il était au courant pourquoi ils
ont gueulé comme ça pour faire plaisir
aux américains
c'est une point de remarques sans sais
rien moi ce que je trouve extraordinaire
c'est qu'on était en irak y est j'ai vu
les délais mais le député anglais
que je sache l'angleterre en plus du
parti de tony blair a une position très
claire dans ses dossiers
j'ai vu un député américain j'ai vu
après les députés belges italiens
espagnols on est le seul pays où ce
déplacement a suscité un tel tollé
mais quand vous étiez là bas vous étiez
à l'hôtel al rachid est ce que les gens
du gouvernement de ma chimio de l'elysée
du quai d'orsay vous ont téléphoné aucun
aucun aucun vous allez choisir les gens
ont attendu que vous rentriez pour vous
engueuler nord mais je recevais les
dépêches afp au moins je dis
heureusement qu'à la presse atteindre
aux politiques de se parler ouais qui a
payé qui a payé leur dit qu il va fixer
une fondation l'office français pour le
développement l'industrie de la culture
en réalité c'est une fondation qui est
une fondation de lobbying soyons très
clairs
la france est le deuxième partenaire
économique de l'irak
l'irak s'est pas
liechtenstein ou je ne sais quel pays
c'est un pays qu'elle est 2e rue est la
deuxième réserve de pétrole au monde et
est un pays qui au point de vue échange
représente un vrai potentiel
le premier client le premier client en
terme d' échange avec l'irak c'est la
russie le deuxième c'est la france bien
loin devant l'angleterre bien loin
devant les états unis
donc c'est de l'argent français c'est
l'argent qui viennent d'une société
française c'est de l'argent qui viennent
à ma table et on peut faire des grimaces
mais c'est de l'argent qui viennent une
société de lobbying française le fait de
faire du commerce avec saddam hussein
s'est pas non plus une raison pour le
laisser préparer des armes je viens
d'accord avec vous c'est ce qu'a connu
clair parce que vous croyez que la
france ne fait lors du commerce qu'avec
les puissances démocratiques non dans ce
cas là on ferait peu de commerces
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé là-bas
vous avez vu quoi n'a pas fait le
tourisme parce que je vous assure que
franchement un bagdad en ce moment c'est
pas le pied en ce qui concerne les les
plaisirs touristique non qu'est ce qu'on
a fait la rencontre et une douzaine de
responsables politiques irakiens à
commencer par le premier ministre tarek
aziz à commencer par le président de
l'assemblée nationale sa double m'a dit
et a commencé et a continué par
l'ensemble des commissions
parlementaires
est-ce que vous avez vu des sites jugés
dangereux par les américains ou les
anglais on a vu deux sites
on a vu le site de tammouz en a fui le
site de falloudja 2 alors c'est nous qui
les avons choisi puisqu'il y avait une
liste alors je le dis avec avec beaucoup
de
de sincérité entrepôt de javel est un
produit chimique n'est pas faire la
différence parce que je sais c'est que
ces sites étaient ouverts ce que je sais
aussi c'est que nous y sommes allés avec
deux chaînes de télé française france 2
à laquelle nous sommes une autre chaîne
de télé importante et avec plusieurs
représentants de la presse nationale et
qu'on aurait pu venir avec des avec les
rails des experts le message les
irakiens étaient simples et elodie
regarder ces sites sont ouverts dès ya
vingt-quatre heures après il acceptait
le retour des observateurs de l'onu
est ce que j'anticipe ont peut-être
votre votre question est ce qu'on a été
manipulé par les irakiens sont un
sérieux dans ce genre de d'événements
tout le monde manipule tout le monde
j'allais dire aussi ce qu'ils font rien
sont manipulés par ceux qui agissent
bien sûr que les irakiens ont essayé de
magnifiques de nous manipuler
je dis simplement que ces sites étaient
ouverts je dis simplement que les
parlementaires américains qui avaient
été invités quelques semaines avant nous
aurait pu venir avec des experts
américains
et puis je dis peut-être tout bêtement
que même si c'est stupide si on peut
éviter une guerre mais ça vous dirait
donc ça veut dire que des sites que les
américains jugent dangereux à partir de
vues aériennes disons vous quand vous
êtes en bas dedans vous apercevez qui
sont pas dangereux je m'aperçois qu'à
l'instant t où j'y suis rien mais
peut-être caristan de témoins ont
attesté plus plusieurs il ya quelque
chose et puis soyons sérieux
quelles sont les armes aujourd'hui de
destruction massive les armes chimiques
les armes bactériologiques
moi je me souviens que dans un pays très
démocratique qui s'appelle états unis à
oklahoma city
le siège du fbi ya peut-être plus de 100
morts à sauter par quelques excités qui
avait fabriqué une arme partir d'engrais
donc c'est évident que j'ai pas vous
dire que l'irak est totalement innocent
je n'ai aucun pouvoir
il n'en suis pas convaincu c'est évident
que j'ai pas vous dire que l'irak n'a
aucune arme qui simplement que ce jour
là il était prêt à accepter les
observateurs c'est l'importance que vous
dites c'est à dire que les américains
nous raconte des histoires alors quand
il dit qu avec l on raconte des
histoires si simplement qu'aujourd'hui
on n'a aucune preuve que la meilleure
preuve comme de vendée le président de
la république comme le demande le
ministre des affaires étrangères en
france comme le demande la france c'est
d'accepter le retour des observateurs de
l'onu
c'est ce qui a été accepté par l'irak et
qui j'espère ira jusqu'à son terme
alors vous avez rapporté au président
chirac a un message de tarek aziz
on pense ainsi le président de la
république chirac nous avons rapporté
aux autorités diplomatiques le message
tarkasis c'est quoi ce message ce
message d'ouverture devrait pas vous
demander à exactement
quoi comme ça à l'alliance joue un petit
à la louche
elle l'a c'est un truc sympa c'est allez
mettez vous à la place de l'irak
aujourd'hui dira que je veux dire en
dehors du discours de propagande à sa
mort c'est un peuple brave un peu tout
est prêt à affronter la guerre c'est
aussi un peuple qui a conscience de ses
forces et de ses faiblesses et
aujourd'hui je veux dire je crois que
l'irak cherche une porte de sortie et le
message qui a été passée c'est simple
c'est le dire que tous les irakiens et
comme pour beaucoup de pays du
moyen-orient
même si ça peut faire sourire en france
je pense que la france a une autre image
que les états unis les insurgés pas sûr
du tout j'espère bien heureusement
plutôt fier d'être dans un harry parce
que peut-être l'héritage gaulliste fait
qu'on n'est pas considérée comme les
américains les anglais et est peut-être
le message que nous avions apporté avec
didier julia avec eric diard last et
peut-être de dire que la france là
dedans même si on n'est pas aussi fort
que les américains il ya au moment où la
voix ça compte autant que des dizaines
d'armes nucléaires vous pensez que
jacques chirac se souvient de la
politique arabe du général de gaulle
quand même j'en suis persuadé tant mieux
les irakiens aussi un look rock va y
avoir la guerre en irak
j'espère que non je suis chez rien
décider quand même non il a l'air décidé
mais mais qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on a sur une scène
internationale des résolutions de l'onu
les résolutions de l'onu disent quoi
elles disent il faut que l'irak accepte
le retour des inspecteurs de l'onu pour
prouver que ce pays n'a pas d'armes de
destruction massive
c'est la politique que défend la france
elle dit pas que l'irak doit changer de
régime
même si je répète je n'approuve pas ce
régime elle ne dit pas que l'irak ou à
changer complètement de politique
la france défend cette position jacques
chirac défend cette position est dans
mon avis dans la pure tradition
gaullienne et donc à mon avis la france
a une carte à jouer dans ce pays on vous
dit que vous défendez pas ce régime
enfin saddam hussein saint laïc les
américains essaient de le mettre dans le
même sac qu'oussama ben laden mais ça
n'a rien avoir contre une dictature
laïque est une dictature
il s'explique je préfère une dictature
laïque et quand j'étais à bagdad
à un moment j'ai une réception je vais
pas dire l'ambassade de france puisque
officiellement nous avons plus de
relations diplomatiques mais je crois
que c'est le le poste et les intérêts
français en irak
j'ai rencontré la bellongue tom le
nombre vient la baie d'antongil qui
était en soutane blanche qui m'a dit je
suis le représentant de la nonciature
dit le représentant du vatican
j mais vous vous êtes comme ça on ira
qui m'a dit aucun problème dans ce pays
tout le monde le salue dans ce pays tout
le monde me dit bonjour
par contre dans un pays voisin que vous
devinez j'ai un prêtre qui a été arrêté
parce qu'il portait les hosties way
l'irak est un pays qui n'a rien de
démocratique mais d'ailleurs terville
arrêt quasi c4 à dire oui tout à fait
tout à fait les raisons tarek aziz et
chrétiens et et moi ce qui me see me
surprendre dans notre pays la france
c'est pardonnez moi pendant la
méconnaissance de nos concitoyens sur ce
dossier et je pense que parlement les
américains jouent aussi là dessus
alors quand on vous dit que votre
attitude est comparable à celle de
certains pacifistes en 1940 qui voulait
absolument être copain avec qui tu es
actuellement vous êtes dans une
stratégie munich oiseaux répondez quoi
d'abord il faut quand même regarder une
certaine une certaine mesure je ne pense
pas que saddam hussein soit clair ce
n'est pas un démocrate
ni'lin et encore moins l'autre puis
simplement que dans une région où si
vous trouvez un régime démocratique vous
me le signale et ça m'intéresse mais
j'en trouve pas beaucoup dans une région
oui israël de les raisons c'est être le
seul à prendre un animal en citer un
second dans une région les régimes
démocratiques sont gras roues uniques
on a un pays qui est pas débat
démocratique mais laïque
face à la montée des listes des
extrémismes et bien je pense que 2g mort
un pays qui traditionnellement est un
ami de la france
je pense que le rôle de la france et
peut-être de favoriser la paix pour
éviter que ce pays subissent une guerre
de plus et je rajoute la 2e guerre
mondiale a été certainement la plus
cruelle la plus horrible que nous ayons
connu dix ans après dix ans après ou
douze ans après 1945
nous signons nous la france un traité
d'amitié avec l'allemagne l'irak envahi
le koweit
c'est une faute impardonnable douze ans
après se payer toujours sous embargo
quel est le pays qui accepterait douze
ans après d'être toujours son embargo
et je regardais avant de rentrer sur le
plateau le rappel de la semaine dernière
vous avez pas encore quand on fabrique
des générations de désespérée qui après
se mettre des ceintures de bon des
ceintures avec des bombes et se font
sauter eux mêmes dites vous bien que en
irak depuis dix ans il ya une génération
qui grandit sous l'embargo sous le
blocus et qui aujourd'hui demandent
simplement à être un pays normal il ya
je pleure sur les morts des twin towers
mais un miracle les twin towers c'est
quasiment tous les deux mois merci
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant ap
samad moussaoui
[Musique]
qui
bonsoir bonsoir
thierry mariani donc qui rentre d'irak
abou hammad moussaoui donc vous avez 35
ans vous êtes professeur en
électrotechnique à montpellier vous êtes
le frère de zacarias moussaoui qui est
inculpé depuis décembre 2001 c'était le
premier inculpé par la justice
américaine pour les attentats du 11
septembre il est soupçonné d'avoir été
le 20e pirate aux ordres du réseau al
qaïda six chefs d'accusation pèsent
contre lui dont quatre sont passibles de
la peine de mort
le procès débutera le 6 janvier 2003 ce
verdict en plus c'est une véritable épée
de damoclès sur les relations franco
américaines puisque zacarias moussaoui
votre frère est de nationalité française
et qu'en france comme vous le savez
évidemment on a aboli la peine de mort
alors vous publiez
zacarias moussaoui mon frère chez denoël
un pacte avec la collaboration de la
journaliste florence boukila interview
vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors le 13 septembre 2001 vous roulez
sur le plateau de milo entre mende et
montpellier c'est jeudi
la semaine est finie la nuit tombe vous
écouter la radio france info
hélas dans l'immensité des cévennes vous
entendez une voix qui dit votre nom
moussaoui où elle dit zacarias moussaoui
franco algérien a été arrêté en relation
avec les attentats du 11 septembre
depuis le 17 août et je crois qu'ils
avaient ajouté un prénom ahmed ou un
autre prénom
oui et puis disait franco-algérien donc
ma première réaction c'était de dire
zacarias moussaoui franco algérien bon
c'est pas c'est pas franco marocain il
disait à pied il ajoutait il disait né à
saint jean de luz donc là ma gorge se
serre et et alors on va commencer par le
commencement votre père était carreleur
au maroc quand il a rencontré votre mère
qui à l'époque avait 14 ans alors on n'a
jamais su en fait si votre mère avait
voulu de toute force quitté son foyer
pour se marier avec votre père ou au
contraire si elle était mariée de force
ma mère dit qu elle a été mariée de
force ma grand mère dit que c'est elle
qui a voulu se marier
mon oncle dit que c'est elle qui a voulu
se marier ma tante dit que c'est elle
qui a voulu se marier il ya l'essentiel
n'est pas là
en tout cas c'est clair que des années
plus tard elle en a gardé une douleur et
une souffrance
elle s'en est largement exprimés
l'essentiel pour elle il est là en fait
c'est que ce mariage au départ c'était
une douleur quoi pour elle alors deux
filles naissent et puis votre père
décide d'émigrer en france en 1965 sur
la côte basque et vous naissez vous donc
en 1967 et votre frère
zacharias en 1968 et trois ans après en
vos parents divorcent et vous partez
tous les deux avec votre mère à mulhouse
ou votre mère a trouvé du travail alors
pourquoi mulhouse
alors je ne sais pas j'étais trop jeune
je ne sais pas je sais qu'on s'est
retrouvé dans un dans un orphelinat qui
s'appelle le home saint jean oui parce
que votre mère peut pas vous gardez donc
un hymne est à la dass j'imagine que ça
doit être des moments terribles pour
elle et c'est vrai que cet endroit pour
nous c'était un nombre est un petit peu
d'effroi en même temps on était rassuré
parce que il y avait des parquets en
bois il y avait de gros édredon il
faisait chaud c'était bien chauffé et en
même temps on était un petit peu effrayé
parce qu'on n'avait pas nos parents
ouais et puis on voyait tous ces gens
nous disaient c'est un orphelinat
donc vous comprenez chaque jour comme si
on était des invités comme si on allait
partir demain 1
mais à chaque jour en succès des
annonces a duré un an oui ça a duré plus
d'un an
ça a marqué sa carrière vous pensé cette
séparation de sa mère je pense que ça a
marqué toute la famille je pense que ça
a marqué toute la famille parce que dans
cet orphelinat je pense que c'est des
endroits un petit peu où il n'y a pas
d'autorité parentale dont les éducateurs
sarr pense pas la famille ça ne pose pas
les parents mais alors en plus quand
votre père vient vous voir vous partez
en courant parce que votre mère vous a
expliqué que votre père était un méchant
qui lui a fait du mal
donc quand vous voyez votre père
s'approcher pour vous parler vous partez
en courant et d'ailleurs il finit par se
lasser
il vient plus et puis un jour votre mère
vous dis ben oui
a laissé tomber ben oui c'est triste
c'est pas quelque chose mais c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne comprenait pas
nous d'un côté on avait notre mère qui
ne disait que qui nous montrer son
affection qui nous avait extirpé de
l'orphelinat pour nous c'était c'est
formidable c'est une héroïne pour nous
et puis dans l'autre côté on avait ce
père qui était absent et qui était
accusé de tous les maux donc pour pour
nous c'était pas difficile de le fuir ce
n'était pas difficile quand ils arrivent
et vous partiez en partant au courant en
partant au courant d'ailleurs je me
raconte cet épisode dans le livre il
venait nous chercher nous a fait monter
dans une 4l et en deux 2 ans et
regardent avec mon frangin on a ouvert
chacun une porte et on a sauté en
courant et on s'est sauvés qu'apprend on
l'a plus revu pendant des années parce
qu'il s'est lassé il a fini par se
lasser
alors un jour votre maire annonce que
vous avez quitté l'est de la france pour
vous installer à narbonne et zacharias
lui veut rester à mulhouse
parce qu'il espère devenir joueur de
hand ball professionnel et c'est une
vraie déchirure pour l'essai de ce
départ pour narbonne
oui c'est vrai c'est quelque chose qu'il
a marqué c'est quelque chose ce même des
années plus tard une qualité la fin
qu'il en parlait encore avec un avec du
regret parce que il s'éclatait il était
dans un club l'as aix ptt mulhouse il
joue au handball il était reconnu il
avait le poste de pivot
il était très performant il était très
apprécié et puis toujours en un maire
nous a sorti une carte à la maison nous
a dit bon on va dans le sud au soleil on
va voter
on va décider ensemble quelle ville on
va choisir on a pris une carte on a
mesuré sur la carte à distance avec la
mère la plus proche c'est et narbonne
donc on a dit on va aller à narbonne en
tous les cas pour sa carrière
quelque chose se brise il en gardera
toujours une certaine rancoeur vous
dites dans votre livre une certaine
amertume
moi je dirais c'est comme une fêlure dit
fêlure qui vient se mettre après une
autre fêlures je me suis rendu compte
avec du recul que il n'y a pas d'élément
clé il ya les petites fêlures des
petites marques des coups de canifs
troisième fêlures l'arrivée à narbonne
alors là c'est terrible parce que vous
êtes marocain mais vous êtes assez assez
noir de
le pot et vous avé l'accent alsacien
alors évidemment quand vous arrivez à
narbonne pour les gens là-bas êtes
d'espèces de martien en quelque sorte
mais ça fait quand c'est arrivé comme ça
et que vous parlez comme ça c'est pas
très courant voyez voilà ça fait plutôt
sourire mais voilà maintenant quand on
est adulte on reprends mes enfants c'est
pas quelque chose d'évident
oui alors il faut vous expliquer à tout
le monde la vérité faut vous expliquez
vous êtes arabe en fait donc c'est qu'en
général on n'a pas besoin de l'expliquer
vous obligé d'expliquer ça des fois on
nous prend on nous prenait pour des
antilles et camp nou camp quand vous
prendre pour un entier qu'on est enfant
c'est ça va c'est plutôt sympathique
oui le contact est plutôt sympathique
les antilles le rhum la bibine
c'est plutôt sympa et un contact qui se
fait mais comme on dit arabe maghrébin
là tout de suite ça devient plus lourd
alors adolescent vous êtes plutôt sage
parce que vous avez qu'une peur c'est
d'avoir un casier judiciaire et ne pas
pouvoir faire des études poussées
d'ailleurs à l'époque zacharias est très
très droit il dit attention il faut pas
qu'on fasse de conneries quoi exactement
crois que c'est le marque le passage à à
l'orphelinat qui nous a fait prendre
conscience de ça qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait pas laisser passer les
opportunités de formation est depuis
très jeune c'est mon frère qui me
poussait qui me dit attention il faut
qu'on fasse des études faut pas que
qu'on se laisse aller parce que dans le
quartier on habitait d'inviter la cité
razimbaud à narbonne c'est cité hlm des
bâtiments de quatre étages une quinzaine
de blocs des terrains vagues
les gamins qui traîne qui squattent dans
l'hérault qui tiennent les murs
l'environnement c'est pas un
environnement créé traître et
épanouissement très ouverts quoi c c'est
le monde dans la stagnation
on attend que le temps passe dgt tiff
voilà alors côté études ça va pas si mal
mais côté familial ça s'arrange pas du
tout un jour vous promener dans la rue à
narbonne avec votre votre frère
zacharias et il ya quelqu'un qui vous
arrête comme ça qui vous dit mais vous
n'êtes pas les fils moussaoui vous alors
vous dites oui oui bien sur wii vous
connaissez notre père et l'homme vous
réponds oui j'étais en prison avec lui
notre première réaction ça a été de se
regarder et puis de regarder si les
personnes qui entendait que tout de
suite on s'est sentis senti mal à l'aise
et puis tout si tu apprendras demander
des nouvelles
imaginez en fait arrêter dans la rue par
quelqu'un qui vous dit qu'il est en
prison avec votre père donc c'était
c'était quelque chose de c'est une
déchirure de plus oui c'est de nouveau
un petit canif alors à ce moment là ça
va un peu mieux pour votre frères
acariès il rencontre fanni qui est
blonde à la peau blanche et aux yeux
clairs et ils ont une histoire d'amour
qui va d'ailleurs duré dix ans mais les
parents de familles sont un racisme
affligeant ils l'aiment pas c'est ce que
dit fanny c'est ce que disait zakaria
moi j'ai pas vu de démonstration de
racisme virulent voyez c'était une
indifférence et comme je le disais dans
le livre peut-être que fanny à a le tort
de de dévoiler les propos qui se
tiennent chez elle dans l'intimité de la
maison donc il ya un mépris qui s'est
installée une distance
au début nous vous savez quand on était
plus jeunes on pensait que les gens
racistes
c'était uniquement des gens qui
n'étaient pas cultivé que c'est des gens
qui qui qui avait peur de l'autre qui
n'avait jamais été en contact avec
l'autre ont compensé que de montrer tel
qu'on est de se montrer tel qu'on était
d'essayer d'être ouvert de communiquer
d'aller vers l'autre ça faisait tomber
les barrières non non non c'est pas
aussi simple c'est plus compliqué que ça
à l'époque vous découvrez que votre
frère à carrias n'aime plus votre mère
oui c'est terrible vite qu'ils la
regardent mais pas comme on regarde une
mère il la regarde froidement avec
distance avec recul faut dire qu'ils
avaient des conflits il avait dès l'âge
de 14 ans il avait des config mais très
très dur moi je ne comprenais pas âgées
j'ai jamais compris ça il était capable
de de s'engueuler de se disputer de 18h
à 2h du matin
c'est épuisant surtout quand ça se passe
tous les jours alors parlez beaucoup
avec votre mère pour se disputer
apparemment mais votre mère vous a
jamais parlé à rabat la maison déjà je
me rends compte qu'effectivement on
parlait pas arabe à la maison on
connaissait pas les gens de notre
famille on connaissait pas notre culture
on connaissait pas notre tradition le
peu de fois où on a posé des questions
par exemple quand on veut parler on veut
apprendre une langue
on a besoin d'être mis en confiance si à
chaque fois que vous voulez apprendre
une langue
quoi vous dit un mot de travers ou en
hausse et mal on se met à rire toute
velléité quoi votre mère vous a jamais
parlé non plus de religion la religion
musulmane je m'étais jamais été apprises
ce qui a fait que vous n'avez pas de
repères en fait c'est on était ignares
on va dire ce qui est on dignard je dois
dire que je connaissais enfants je
connais c'est plus le catholicisme que
la religion musulmane
en alsace il n'y a pas de séparation de
l'église et de l'état
je me rappelle à l'école primaire et ben
on aller au catéchisme
moi je dis aux curés je suis musulman
mais bon à part le mot musulman je
savais pas très bien ce que ça ce qu'il
y avait derrière et puis bon il nous
racontait des histoires bon je savais
donc les gens fêter noël je savais
pourquoi il y avait la toussaint je
savais pourquoi
mais le ramadan je ne savais pas
pourquoi la fête de la naissance du
prophète mohamed je ne savais pas
pourquoi pourquoi les gens faisaient la
prière comment il faisait la prière je
ne savais pas pourquoi des ignares donc
vous fréquentez pas beaucoup d'arabes
vous dit même que votre mère était assez
xénophobe et que ce qu'elle disait dans
la bouche de d'un un français de souche
sera paru comme des propos extrêmement
xénophobe limite front national quoi
écoutez moi quand j'étais quand j'étais
plus jeune avec mofaz ça nous gêne et ça
ne gênait beaucoup ça nous gênait
beaucoup je n'avais pas peut-être les
mots pour dire si tels propos et
xénophobes ou pas mais on se sentait
très mal à l'aise
pourquoi parce que dès qu'il y avait un
maghrébin c'était les moqueries
c'était c'était c'était nous renvoyer
une image qui est pas une image positive
donc on sentait mal à l'aise nous en
fait alors vous n'êtes pas non plus
intégrée évidemment parmi les français
de souche et vous raconter dans votre
livre une anecdote assez terrible vous
êtes à mulhouse vous êtes rue
kaysersberg dans un espace vert qui est
en bas de l'immeuble où vous habitez et
vous jouer aux billes
avec des petits copains en rentrant de
l'école jusqu'au jour où le petit garçon
vous dit je ne peux pas jouer avec vous
alors mes parents me l'ont interdite
alors vous dites pour ce soir non c'est
pour tout le temps pourquoi parce que
vous êtes des [ __ ] ça c'était là notre
première expérience par un proche et
c'est vrai que moi elle m'est restée en
mémoire parce que c'était quelqu'un que
je côtoyais c'était quelqu'un avec qui
je m'amusais c'est quelqu'un avec qui je
rigolais depuis du jour au lendemain il
ya eu ces changements cette cassure mais
ça c'est de la gnognotte à côté d'eux
d'autres expériences
alors il ya un événement important c'est
le 14 juillet 1989 vous êtes victime
d'une agression raciste à narbonne donc
quand vous courrez voir les policiers
pour chercher un abri pour qu'ils vous
protège
il vous accueille avec des gaz
lacrymogènes parce que pour eux un arabe
est coupable d'office à la saaq arias le
voit il en souffre presque plus que vous
et là aussi ça a dû faire partie des
petites fêlures qui ont tout à fait un
type qui m'arrêtent dans la rue
il me tape sur l'épaule je me retourne
mais une droite à soir de 14 juillet je
m'en vais en courant au coin de
l'immeuble
je tombe sur une patrouille de police
qu'est ce que je fais le réflexe de la
bouche en sang
je m'arrête je demande de l'aide et puis
là il reste ils me regardent et puis le
type il arrive il veut me finir
et puis un policier m'attrape par les
cheveux il me sort une bombe lacrymogène
et il me gaz je me sauve je m'évanouis
puis j'ai la chance que de m'évanouir
devant un restaurant dans lequel il ya
des amis qui sont en train de dîner ils
sont sortis ils sont venus voir qu'est
ce qu'il y avait ils m'ont montréal y
met
ils m'ont emmené à l'hôpital et ils ont
fait ils ont fait fuir le le type mais
c'est pas c'est pas le coup de poing qui
m'a fait mal et c'est pas le coup de
poing qui m'avait révolté ce qui m'avait
révoltés à l'époque parce que j'étais
j'étais jeune j'étais un jeune homme
c'est le manque de réaction des flics
français jc que d'accord il y avait la
cohue d'accord c'était le 14 juillet
d'accord il y avait du monde mais c'est
que entre deux le choix il a évité fait
forcément c'était moi ouais et c'est
vrai que pendant longtemps j'en ai gardé
un ressentiment et pendant longtemps ça
tu es la confiance il a fallu plus
d'expérience plus de plus d'épreuves
pour relativiser alors zakaria souffre
plus que vous finalement de cette
mésaventure et puis après c'est la
guerre du golfe alors là d'un seul coup
il a le sentiment d'appartenir à l'autre
monde celui qui était attaqué par les
américains il jeudi il
je dirais on est les étudiants et puis
tout une sorte une partie de la
population parce que moi je me rappelle
les positions de jean pierre chevènement
il était il était contre l'attack en
irak 1 il ya d'autres moyens que de
bombarder des populations civiles
maintenant il faut raison garder on
était pas on n'était pas pour saddam
hussein ah non absolument pas la
dictature le gazage des populations
kurdes on n'était pas pour ça nous ce
qu'on voyait uniquement c'était une
population civile qui allait se faire
taper dessus et en même temps que cela
on avait des gens qui il était là il
s'éclate et il se répandait en en
réjouissances presque devant le lot mis
la grandeur et la beauté des frappes
chirurgicales qui ont fait des massacres
de populations d'un jeu vidéo comme un
jeu vidéo
les oublier complètement qui avaient des
populations civiles dernier sous les
bombes c'est ce que veut éviter notre
amie marie à nice pour ça qu'il est
parti à bagdad alors zacharias
fréquentes à ce moment là la cafétaria
de la cité universitaire de montpellier
il rencontre des étudiants étrangers
donc il est soumis sûrement à ce
moment-là certaine influence et il part
assez rapidement en angleterre et au
début il revient voir fanny tous les 4
mois au départ revient assez souvent
finalement mais ils commencent à changer
votre épouse fouzia ge préparent le
capes donc elle fait des études lui lui
explique un jour où il revient comme ça
qu'il faut pas que les filles phase
d'étude à petit à petit devient étranger
avoue une certaine façon au départ avec
mon épouse fouzia on comprenait pas
fouzia elle a fait des études de
biologie la fin troisième cycle de
neuropsychopharmacologie elle préparait
un capes de biologie les années
précédentes avant qu'il parte en
angleterre mon frère était le premier à
l'encourager faut savoir que mon frère
il n'avait qu'une idée qu'une obsession
c'était la réussite professionnelle
son objectif c'était monté une
entreprise qu'on fasse d'import export
entre les pays du maghreb les pays du
golfe et c'est pour ça qu'ils étaient
partis en angleterre pour améliorer ses
connaissances en anglais donc quelques
mois plus tard on le voit revenir et
qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans son discours
on fait pourquoi tu fais ça de toute
façon rester à la maison
c était mieux à la maison et puis de
toute façon tu sais les femmes après
tout hein hein vous voyez changé alors
il se met à porter la barbe il se rase
le crâne
il commence à porter des pantalons à mi
mollet et un jour l'une de vos soeur
jamila s'habille pour sortir habillé
comme comment s'habille ici et zacharias
la regarde et lui dit mais tu vas pas
sortir habillé comme une [ __ ] dire que
là vous comprenez d'un seul coup qu'il
est passé l'autre côté moi quand elle
m'a raconté ça ça m'a fait mal au coeur
et je me suis dit qu'il y avait quelque
chose qui était vraiment brisé chez lui
moi j'ai pris ça vraiment pour vraiment
un signe de détresse alors il avait été
recruté par une secte wahhabite et vous
vous lui donnez à ce moment là des
brochures qui critiquent le wahhabisme
et et finalement au lieu de le ramener
dans le droit chemin si on peut dire ça
ne fait que renforcer sa détermination
je ne connaissais pas j'étais pas du
tout avertit mois par rapport à cette
secte de la secte wahhabite où les
coteaux beast j'étais pas du tout
avertira ça je connaissais pas
et puis donc je savais qu'en angleterre
je lisais les journaux je savais qu'en
angleterre avec des groupes extrémistes
je savais qu'il y avait les groupes
wahhabites donc j'allais dans une
mosquée à montpellier il y avait la
documentation sur les wahhabites je lui
donne moi j'avais le réflexe mon frère
c'est un universitaire lorsqu'il veut
s'informer sur un sujet il se fait une
bibliographie
ils se constituent une documentation
donc à partir des informations que je
vais lui donner il va pouvoir avoir des
éléments pourraient être critiques moi
c'est le raisonnement manif que j'avais
mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on lutte
contre une secte
là c'est l'échec assuré
quand on a quelqu'un qui est embrigadé
dans une secte il faut d'abord cultivée
la relation il faut cultiver les
sentiments l'attachement car c'est par
le coeur qu'on arrive à faire sortir
quelqu'un d'une secte c'est pas par la
raison dans un premier temps mais la
raison elle est là elle est importante
parce que quand on vient avec les
arguments et que l'on montre à quel
point le wahhabisme c'est une secte qui
est apparue il ya 250 ans et qu'on
montre à partir des arguments de la
religion que leurs propos leurs propos
d'excommunication des populations
entières leur propose de légitimation de
l'assassinât et du meurtre et que ce
sont des choses qui sont infondés qui
n'existe pas dans l'islam sunnite savoir
que les théologiens musulmans sunnites
depuis 250 ans il montre du doigt et met
en garde contre le wahhabisme
si on montre cette réalité là là la
réaction n'est plus la même mais vous
parlez du wahhabisme comme d'une siècle
enfin c'est quand même la religion
officielle de l'arabie saoudite
officiellement en arabie saoudite
on appelle ça le royaume wahhabite c'est
un fait si on interroge les la
population d'arabie vont vous dire on
est en dali et quand l'idéologie où elle
habite pénètre en europe
c'est pas en disant on est aux arbitres
parce que les wahhabites ne sont pas
aimés ils vous disent ils disent la
population musulmane nous sommes
emballés à dire une des quatre écoles de
jurisprudence qu'on appelle l'islam
sunnite et par cette porte là ils vont
essayer de rentrer et petit à petit ce
qu'ils vont essayer de faire c'est faire
croire à la population musulmane à la
jeunesse musulmane qu'ils sont eux les
tenants et les garants de la légalité et
de la légitimité religieuse musulmane
alors vous vous êtes sunnite
tout à fait vous êtes d'une tendance qui
s'appelle léa bâche est ce que vous nous
expliquer en quoi parce que vous savez
les français connaissent pas très bien
là
m religion de leur pays c'est quand même
un drame les ardèche ce sont des
sunnites qui ont peut-être plus pris
conscience que d'autres d'accord qu'il
fallait aider la communauté musulmane à
lutter contre l'extrémisme
le problème c'est que les wahhabites
détiennent l'argent du monde musulman et
vous dites qu'ils occupent 90 % du
linéaire islamistes en vente libre
leurs livres sont ceux qu'on trouve le
plus le plus facilement en europe
oui ça c'était c'est une mais deuxième
constatation quand j'ai vu mon frère me
glisser des mains donc j'ai voulu aller
me nous renseigner me documenter qu'est
ce que j'ai fait bien le réflexe je vais
dans une librairie maghrébine là où pour
150 francs à l'époque 150 francs on
ressort avec des bouquins et puis quand
on discute avec le libraire et vous
apprend que en réalité les livres ils
payent pas on lui donne et on lui dit
battu les payera quand comme quand tu
veux je sais pas quel libraire peut
fonctionner comme ça donc l'argent c'est
important parce que le fait c'est comme
dans un supermarché vous rentrez vous
trouvez 80% des linéaires qui sont
remplis de l'idéologie où habite
économistes le jeune kenyan france qui
comme moi n'a pas n'a pas d'histoire n'a
pas connaissance de la culture ne remets
pas de repères qu'est-ce qui va croire
il pourrait croire que c'est
représentatif du monde sunnite
alors ça n'a rien à voir est-ce que vous
pensez que les livres où habite
devraient être interdits à la vente en
france par exemple a tout à fait bien
sûr mais c'est pas l'unique moyen on
peut pas remplacer l'éducation c'est
c'est irremplaçable c'est une nécessité
moi je suis enseignant moi je veux le
bien moi je veux que les jeunes que je
forme au lycée ben ils soient utiles
pour eux mêmes pour leurs familles pour
la société j'ai pas envie qu'il se
laisse embrigadé par un groupe
extrémiste qui se passe sautée ou qui
tuent des gens je voudrais que les gens
de bonne volonté
eh bien ils se révoltent aussi dans quel
sens
dès qu'on sache que derrière l'idéologie
de la haine et la terreur il ya le
wahhabisme ya l'idéologie c'est trop tôt
et qu'il ya des gens qui ont de l'argent
et qui pousse la vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
de zacarias moussaoui dans les banlieues
françaises
je ne sais pas mais je sais que
potentiellement il ya une vraie détresse
sociale et que les wahhabites et les
adeptes de ses tubes
ils savent utiliser sept
détresse sociale pour capter les gens
c'est sûr qu'il faut un profil
particulier c'est sûr qu'il faut être
réceptif c'est pas tout le monde mais il
ya plusieurs niveaux vous savez il ya
des rabatteurs
ce sont les adeptes de l'idéologie de
c'est trop tôt et puis après il ya ce
qui met les bombes et je sais qu'en
france il ya beaucoup de rabatteurs vous
croyez qu'en france aujourd'hui le
politiquement correct interdit d' dont
parlait de ça par peur de l'amalgamé
pour éviter finalement que les gens
considèrent tous les tous les musulmans
comme des terroristes en puissance
moi je pense qu'il faudrait il faudrait
casser ce tabou et il faudrait essayer
de lancer le débat mais moi j'ai
j'apporte ma pierre vous aussi d'autres
peuvent l'apporter
et c'est clair que si on casse ce tabou
là les choses vont aller on va pas
refaire le monde
non mais les choses vont un peu mieux
comment ça peut aller mais alors acariès
vous l'avais pas revu depuis 1995
vous avez un contact avec lui depuis son
arrestation
non il m'a adressé un message dans une
de ses lettres il me disait qu'il
m'embrasser et mis à part ça non je n'ai
pas eu de contacts pouvait pas aller aux
états unis parce que vous craignez
d'être gardés par les autorités
américaines jusqu'au procès comme témoin
donc vous n'y allez pas oui c'est pour
ça oui c'est pour ça ce qui est terrible
avec zakaria c'est que dans ses
déclarations il persiste et signe
dire que même maintenant où il au secret
dans une prison américaine
il a pas de repentir je vous fais pas
dire c'est terrible mois moi j'attends
le moment où peut-être il y aura un
recul qui sera pris par lui et il me
remettra en cause un peu les idéologies
qui l'a amené là où il se trouve et où
il manifestera un repentir il attend ça
avec beaucoup d'impatience
imaginez que votre frère zacarias
moussaoui regardent cette émission est
ce que vous avez quelque chose regardez
votre caméra est ce que vous avez
quelque chose lui dire ben moi si je
pouvais voir mon frère en face de moi je
veux dire
tout homme tant qu'il est vivant il a la
possibilité de changer et que c'est pas
parce qu'on a fait des erreurs dans le
passé que on peut pas être meilleure et
qu'il faut avoir le courage de
reconnaître ses erreurs et d'expliquer
en quoi on a fait des erreurs parce que
dans sa situation son cas c'est devenu
un cas qui emblématique et il faudrait
pas qu'elle ait d'autres qui suivent son
exemple
merci ça va de bouchaoui
zacarias moussaoui confrères de chez
denoël impact
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors thierry mariani j'imagine que vous
n'avez pas été insensible aux
déclarations du frère de zacarias
moussaoui parce que j'ai trouvé très
courageux et dans son discours se dire
je suis musulman mais il ya des formes
de d'islam qu'on veut pas accepter et je
crois dans toute religion il est des
riffs il ya eu des dérives dans la
religion catholique on parvenir à
l'acquisition il ya cinq ou six siècles
il ya des dérives aujourd'hui dans les
religions islamisme et je crois que
l'honneur des musulmans c'est de savoir
quand cette religion prend un aspect
excessive de les combattre
merci et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'accueille michèle bernier et francis
huster
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gilles bernier francis huster
[Musique]
comment il va votre papa vous il a super
bien mon papa baxter d'amour samax
cardamome va très bien vous étiez en
vacances avec lui à verdun il parle des
ouïes choisis pas mes racines werder
mais oui parce que ma grand mère a été
garde barrière à 30 km de verdun et donc
il y as familiaux ont fait que la maison
elle est restée là bas elle aurait pu
être garde barrière à monaco où ouattara
oui mais ben non je pense qu'il ya des
gens qui vont à saint tropez déportés
allons alors le démon de midi est passé
à la télé dimanche dernier sur france 3
c'est un petit peu la clôture d'une
grande aventure on vous l'avait joué
combien de fois 600 fois et ça fait
combien de gens ça cent mille cinq cent
mille personnes
oui
alors il ya eu la tv imagine qu'une
personne et cassettes un dvd des barbie
avec des filles quand des corps d'autres
qu'on est chapeautée week-end [ __ ]
des toits et bientôt un film et bientôt
un film voilà qui est en train de
s'écrire
alors attendre en fête du cinéma vous
avez tourné avec peter greenaway c'est
quand même vachement classe mois la
somme scotch et puis alors un film où
vous êtes la demi-soeur d'arielle
dombasle ça j'ai hâte de voir ça et oui
je sais ça le fait l'idée déjà le
casting est bien parce que les jardins
quand on dit ça ces marais c'est
agréable
[Musique]
elle va commencer c'est un rallye très
bien très bien elle est en train de
tourner un film avec jean louis lorenzi
sur la guerre 14 18 un très beau
scénario sur les tranchées et elle va
très bien on a à peu près le même âge
tous les deux ouais hein
vous n'avez pas peur de vous la faire
échouer par un homme de 35 ans et moi ça
me plaît des fois j'ai peur si vous
aimez bon je crois qu'il serait très
heureux si ici mais après je prends tout
de même
j'ai confiance en m sylvain brésilienne
brésil déçoit jamais alors elle peut pas
me décevoir football sewell non
là ce soit un nom je sais pas les roues
une
posez pas de questions non je me pose
pas de questions
non non mais ça va toujours bien avec l
ouïe wes mais non tu es au courant
ben on avait des infos utiles rim enfin
bon bien alors vous allez jouer sur
scène tous les deux ensemble et c'est la
raison de votre présence
alors cette étape de la renaissance la
partir du 25 septembre ça s'appelle lui
livrer ce règlement c'est très connu ça
a été une pièce après ça a été un film
de josiane balasko mise en scène de
josiane balasko qui vous a cherché
comment ça s'est passé
bah c'est josiane balasko qui était venu
me voir au splendid dans le démon midi
et je crois qu'elle a eu à ce moment-là
peut-être l'envi de de retravailler avec
moi puisqu'on avait travaillé ensemble
sur gazon maudit et puis voilà quoi m'a
proposé ce à quelques temps plus tard et
moi je suis tombé par terre déjà parce
que j'adorais cette pièce est le film ça
et puis c'était un honneur pour moi que
josiane me propose d'être sa digne
successeur triste de se et voilà quoi et
après il fallait quelqu'un qui ait rien
à voir avec vous rien moins mal à rien
un mec beau intelligent
qu'est ce qui a manqué jeudi du vrai
théâtre peut pas pas comme nous les
clowns dans cela mais 40 ans directeur
de trop et du conservatoire 10 en france
et enfin voilà des carpettes deux filles
qui lui courent après
le pitch lequel le fait le pitch animaux
c'est à dire c'est l'histoire d'un
célèbre présentateur de télévision un
animateur qui fait une émission qui
s'appelle l'affairé dans le sac et il
transporte sur son dos à chaque fois un
objet on sait pas quoi les gens votent
et un soir il est d'à côté d'une gare
dans un bar avec un copain qu'il laisse
tomber pour partir avec une bute souvent
et qu'il reste du sol et au moment de
partir tout d'un coup il ya déjà un peu
bourré il voit si cette pauvre fille qui
hélas se satisfera lise voilà un simone
et comment sony demandé une cigarette et
puis la conversation s'engage et à ce
moment là ils vont se bourrer la gueule
toute la nuit et puis ce qui est
extraordinaire dans la pièce c'est que
le lendemain matin qu'il ya deux actes
le premier essai dans le bar était au
deuxième acte il est là chez lui bull
est un copain lui téléphone et tout d'un
coup ils voient cette fille arrivée il
sait pas qu'il a passé la nuit avec qui
sait pas ce qui s'est passé alors sa
pièce je suis la surprise vient donc
c'est le 25e septembre au théâtre de la
renaissance vous savez le texte puis ça
va
texte sua la première édition médiation
c'est tout voilà parker voilà damman non
c'est vrai que c'est à pisser de rire
pendant la répétition le problème si
justement de ce d'essayer de se
démarquer de ce qui a déjà été fait est
extraordinairement par les autres quoi
si c'est difficile difficile
alors comme vous êtes deux stars on va
vous faire une interview star by star
c'est là bas que ça se passe alors
d'abord michel vous allez vous asseoir
derrière le petit bureau du late show
vous francisé s'asseoir dans le fauteuil
club et ensuite nous inverserons les
rôles d'accord est-ce que vous mmes
admirer oui merci
alors ça vous fait quoi de jouer avec
moi le trac je vous en doutez est-ce que
vous avez des vues sur moi oui merci
alors on sonne bien sûr c'est à dire oh
là alors on vous a déjà dit que vous
ressembliez plus à gérard holtz ou ou à
gérard philipe
car oui bon ça va alors que gérard
philipe sur un terrain de football oui
puis ça joue très bien en plus seul
est ce qu'on vous a déjà appelé francis
hamster oui toi en répétition pourquoi
ne vous laissez vous pas pousser la
moustache
je les fais dans un film edith et marcel
de claude lelouch je me rappelle qu est
ce que tu étais bien dans ce film c'est
sympa c'est plus sympa est-ce que vous
avez vu mon spectacle démons me dit non
mais j'ai tu m'as envoyé le dvd avant
qu'on commence là la pétition pour que
j'aie singer
mais besoin de se rassurer jeu qu'est ce
que vous aimez le plus en moi ton charme
fou non ce vrai ton charme fou merci mon
amour alors qu'est ce que vous aimez le
moins en mois ça cette question est nul
[Rires]
si vous aviez une chose a changé en moi
ce serait quoi
j'essayerai de donner plus de confiance
en toi justement si c'était à refaire
c'est pas ta referme si c'était à
refaire
qu'est-ce que vous changeriez dans cette
interview tous merci
bon maintenant on change de plaques et
francis huster va devenir comme dans
nuit d'ivresse un vrai animateur de
télévision avoue francis ça vous a fait
quoi la première fois qu'on s'est vu ça
m'a fait drôle parce que comme je suis
amoureuse de toi depuis l'année dernière
ça m'a fait tout drôle je croyais pas
qu'il existait un vrai tu vois moi mon
onze mois mais on va changer détruits
dans la mise en scène
qu'est ce que vous pensiez deux mois
avant la pièce ça on passe à votre avis
qu'est ce que je pense de vous dis bien
que souvent sur les deux mois après la
pièce qu'est-ce que j'ai eu comme chance
a votre avis il ya des chances pour
qu'on prolonge de quoi toi et moi
[Rires]
est-ce que vous avez vu ma chérie télé
le grand patron bien sûr c'est une
longue pierre fresnay dedans et si vous
avez gardez vos cheveux est ce pour
mieux vous démarquer de votre père le
professeur choron
alors oui et non mais j'aurais bien aimé
être tendu mais c'est la moustache à moi
par contre qui me va pas du tout
est ce qu'on vous a déjà dit que vous
ressembliez plus au professeur tournesol
co professeur choron
non on m'a déjà dit professeur cabrol
professeur choron professeur chaudron
professeur genevois
mais je ressemble à mon père
effectivement qu'est ce que vous aimez
le plus chez vous pas grand chose si
vous aimez le moins chez vous a batu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant de bon matin quand on
partait sur les chemins à bicyclette
alors c'est pas yves montand c'est
olivier besancenot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
bonsoir olivier besancenot donc vous
connaissez thierry mariani qui est parti
à bagdad avec deux copains à lui de
l'ump
vous en pensez-quoi comme ça non le
voyage en tant que tel je crois qu'il ya
pas grand chose à en dire il faut de
plus moi j'ai pas de jets pas de
complicité avec le régime de bagdad par
contre ce que je sais c'est
qu'effectivement les états unis risque
de taper très très fort et que moi quand
j'ai commencé à militer au début des
années 90 c'était le père à l'époque qui
avait déjà fait sacrément mal à toute la
population irakienne avec une guerre
dégueulasse et puis un embargo
dégueulasse qu'on estime peut-être à 300
400 500 milles mais on sait pas
exactement voix et puis aujourd'hui il
ya la deuxième couche donc il va falloir
s'opposer à cette deuxième couche jeu
d'accord alors l'ump d'accord avec la
lcr n'est pas vrai mort mais sur la
première guerre autant je pense que la
première guerre avait là c'est une
justification puisqu'à l'époque l'irak
avait envahi le koweit et même si les
deux régimes sont pas tellement
démocratique soyons honnêtes avec quand
même une agression de l'état envers un
autre autant cette fois par contre je
vois pas justification j'espère que
quelles que soient les options on
évitera une guerre parce que à la sortie
vous avez raison c'est que depuis 12 ans
il ya un peuple qui vit sous embargo
il depuis 12 ans peut pas qu'on peut pas
tolérer ça vous êtes d'accord ce
formidable 106
aïe ça tombe sur vous là moi je suis
surtout inquiet parce que j'ai été
frappée quand j'ai lu un livre sur la
guerre 39-45 un livre merveilleux écrit
par jean lambert et jova joumblatt
sauvage blattes et est un rescapé
d'auschwitz ii birkenau
il est rentré dans le four crématoire et
au moment où les portes se sont fermées
menguelet qui avait loupé long l'entrée
était fou de rage il est revenu il a
fait rouvrir les portes il a fait sortir
deux ou trois rangées les portes se sont
refermées tout on a été gazés donc
sauvage blattes dans ce livre le témoins
prévus et donc lui un véritable témoin
de ce qui s'est passé
on peut pas dire qu'il ya pas eu de deux
fours crématoires de chambre de gaz si
on n'a pas joué ce black or quand j'ai
lu ce livre il ya un moment un passage
dans ce livre où on raconte que la croix
rouge avait envoyé des représentants et
que ses représentants quand ils étaient
reçus dans les camps de concentration il
n'y avait rien de mal
tout se passait bien et qui on avait
envoyé danser danser quand des jeunes
d'aider des jeunes représentants de la
croix rouge des gens qui se sont fait
berner entre guillemets d'une certaine
façon
maintenant si on veut discuter pendant
trois heures on peut discuter entre vous
on va simplement s'arrêter à une chose
suivante je vous ai juste une question
comment justifiez vous l'attitude de
saddam hussein qui attaquaient par les
américains réagi en envoyant les scud
sur israël que ce soit israël ou un
autre pays comment expliquez vous cette
attitude est inadmissible
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la position de
la france qui était de demander le
retour des observateurs de l'onu est le
seul moyen d'éviter la guerre
vous pensez que les observateurs de
l'onu vont pas être comme les
observateurs de la croix-rouge berne est
entre guillemets parce que les
observateurs durant 7 ans ont fait un
travail correct
ils ont été ensuite sortie du pays par
saddam hussein je n'approuve pas le
régime jeudi mais simplement le meilleur
moyenne de presse de préserver la paix
c'est de garantir que ce pays n'a plus
d'armes d'un plus de d'armes de
destruction massive
vraiment les yeux dans les yeux est ce
que vous pensez que si saddam hussein
est attaqué imaginons le pire
il est attaqué est ce que vous pensez
qu'il va lancer vraiment que ce soit sur
israël par exemple ou un autre billet
est ce que vous pensez qu'il peut réagir
de cette façon là j'en sais rien mais je
crains et je crois que dans ce genre de
situation la meilleure solution je le
répète c'est leur tour les observateurs
de l'onu je crois que dans cette région
à part israël n'y a pas de régime
démocratique
mais on fait pas la guerre à tous les
régimes sous prétexte qu'ils ne sont pas
les régimes démocratiques
mais dans ce problème international et
une odeur de pétrole que chacun connaît
et bien que dans cette dans ce climat la
france a peut-être un rôle et comme l'a
fait le président de la république comme
on a été trois avec eric diard et didier
julia on essaye de défendre une idée qui
à mon avis la seule peut maintenir la
paix on va s'arrêter là parce que sinon
on peut faire la soirée là dessus c'est
un mot à ajouter un seul nom alors merci
olivier besancenot donc le week-end
dernier à la courneuve c'était la fête
de l'huma on attendait la rentrée
politique de robert hue et on a eu droit
à la vôtre c'est à vous que les
militants du pc demander des autographes
c'est vous qu il félicité pour votre
score aux présidentielles ce que vous
avez fait 4,25 et lui il a fait 3 37
donc bravo olivier besancenot
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous au milieu de cette bonne
humeur au lieu d'être gentil avec tout
le monde vous avez déclaré
l'appareil du parti n'a pas d'avenir
[Musique]
méchant comme ça c'est pas méchant je
crois que je suis lucide mais de façon
c'est un secret de polichinelle que
l'appareil du parti communiste accélère
une crise qui est historique et celle du
stalinisme elle accélère en ayant mis en
orbite le parti communiste bas autour du
parti socialiste pendant plus de cinq
ans mais moi j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour tous les militants du pc leurs
sympathisants leurs électeurs qu'on a
retrouvés dans la rue régulièrement
pendant plus de cinq ans dans les
entreprises y compris la mienne à la
poste et qui comprenait tout simplement
pas pourquoi le samedi le dimanche on se
retrouver ensemble dans la rue
et puis le lundi mardi suivant leurs
députés voter exactement le contraire
sur les bancs de l'assemblée
vous pensez que la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire et l'avenir de la gauche
j'aurais pas cette prétention là je
pense forcément que c'est le meilleur
outil pour construire autre chose mais
nous ce qu'on essaie de dire depuis
quelques temps maintenant c'est qu'en
gros si on était un peu cohérent il
devrait y avoir de gauche
rien à voir plus évidemment mais la
cohérence ce serait qui est de gauche
une gauche
une fois de plus satellisé par le parti
socialiste qui est complètement converti
au libéralisme qui pensent qu'on peut en
gros réconcilie le bien-être social de
l'humanité avec l'économie de marché moi
je leur souhaite bien du courage ça fait
vingt cinq ans que ça coûte et ça fait
plus de 25 ans qu'on se prend le
libéralisme dans la tronche et puis
honnêtement il n'y a plus grand monde
quand on veut aujourd'hui dans les
couches populaires
et puis à notre gauche dont on n'est pas
les seuls représentants c'est aussi ça
l'enthousiasmé dont on se revendique qui
est une gauche sans une gauche sociale
une gauche anticapitaliste et une gauche
féministe qu'une gauche anti guerre
aussi et je crois qu'il ya une
polarisation qui va s'accentuer à gauche
entre entre ces deux courants là un peu
à l'image de ce qu'on voit dans le
mouvement social
est-ce que vous avez dépassé la ligue
communiste révolutionnaire pour faire un
grand parti populaire anti capitaliste
je crois qu'on a toujours le projet de
quelque chose qui est plus large que
nous qui est même plus large que la
seule l'extrême gauche qui sera une fois
de plus de construire un nouveau parti
qui défendrait jusqu'au bout les
intérêts du monde du travail qui
défendrait les intérêts de la jeunesse
face à la droite particulièrement
actuellement que les particulièrement
réac et sécuritaire est sécuritaire je
compte qu'aujourd'hui la france a besoin
d'une autre politique en matière de
sécurité savez je suis maire d'une
commune s'appelle valréas dit l'habitant
pour la première fois cette année j'ai
dû fermer la piscine parce que
pardonnez-moi la piscine toutes les
nuits je le bordel dedans c'est à dire
que les saccages et systématiquement je
pense que la france d'en bas aussi par
moments c'est peut-être de lui donner
les moyens de vivre au quotidien
normalement
voilà peut-être lorsque certains
appellent une politique sécuritaire mais
peut-être que la fille si la politique
sécuritaire c'est de donner le moyen à
la france d'en bas comme la france d'en
haut de vivre normalement de la soutient
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui et
contrairement à olivier besancenot
on a besoin d'une autre politique en
matière de sécurité alors elle la france
des gardes barrières près de verdun un
squale à free gens de la france dans sa
salle de long en large et en travers
ça c'est un truc assez passionnant
attendant l'arrivée de monsieur
besancenot et puis c'est en fait je
trouve que tous ces politiques là était
un peu ennuyeuse depuis quelques années
le fait que tout d'un coup il ya un
président de droite une assemblée de
droite ça vous a secoué les puces quand
même là hein ça vous a remis un peu de
ça non je veux dire parce que tout le
monde vous savez quoi michel même
françois hollande s'est énervé cette
semaine incroyable il a bougé alors
olivier vous donner une très bonne image
de la ligue communiste révolutionnaire
par rapport à krivine qui fait quand
même un petit peu le vieux bolcho
soixante huitard mais alors vous faites
pas beaucoup de références au trotskysme
à vous dit avoir découvert trotsky sur
le tard vous dit pas sûr qu'il aurait
fait mieux que staline
vous dites trotskiste ça n'a pas
vraiment de sens depuis qu'il n'existe
plus de stalinien alors est-ce que vous
ne sauriez pas à la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire ce que robert hue a été
aux parties communes et si vous voulez
un liquidateur de l'idéologie non parce
que l'idéologie de la lcr ça jamais été
le trotskisme en tant que tel une fois
plus d'ailleurs alain krivine a toujours
répété qu'ils se sentaient trotskiste
face aux staliniens comme ils sentaient
juifs face aux antisémites mais que moi
j'ai pas à rougir son jumeau bidon de
l'héritage de mon organisation qui est
l'héritage d'un courant qui
effectivement a combattu le stalinisme
et qui permet comme certains autres
courants mais sont pas très nombreux en
réalité comme les libertaires les
guévariste et quelques autres de pouvoir
dire qu'encore aujourd'hui on peut ne
pas être d'accord avec le capitalisme
sans être accusé de tous les maux sans
être suspecté d'être un staline et en
puissance pour moi le communisme et le
stalinisme ça a jamais été ce sera
jamais la même chose parce qu'en plus
d'être un dictateur sanguinaire
staline a été un contre-révolutionnaire
ça a été l'équivalent de ce qui était
napoléon pour la révolution française
par exemple tout à fait alors en fait
là vous avez été très malin c'est que
l'organisation en lutte ouvrière celle
de arlette laguiller a fait 5 72 vous
avez fait que 4 25 mai ce qui vous a
boosté réellement c'est que le soir du
premier tour
c'est vous qui avait appelé tout le
monde à descendre dans la rue contre le
pen alors que arlette c'est beaucoup
moins prononcé je crois que cela est une
autre série d'éléments c'est en gros le
refus systématique de lutte ouvrière des
propositions unitaires qu'on lui faisait
depuis quelques puis quelques temps
notamment aux élections y compris pour
les élections présidentielle et
législatives qu'elle avait parce qu'elle
avait refusé ou nous on était prêt à
faire cet accord là d'un ayant nos
désaccords qui serait qui se serait
présenté pour la présidentielle nous
c'est autour de la candidature d'arlette
parce que c'était évidemment la city est
prêt à soutenir arlette faire une
campagne commune autour de sa
candidature parce que c'était la plus
populaire d'entre nous alors je disais
coup de génie en 30 secondes le soir du
premier tour appeler les gens à
descendre dans la rue contre le pen lot
de coups de génie savait était celui
d'alain krivine qui avait pris un risque
en vous sortant de son chapeau
vous n'êtes pas un pro de la politique
vous êtes un jeune salarié vous gagnez
6700 francs par mois c'est vrai que ça
tranche avec les autres candidats ça
c'est sûr un plein d'aplomb des gars de
toute façon on a essayé de faire un pari
qui est effectivement paris plutôt
gonflé reste est risqué c'était s'était
gonflée c'était d'essayer de à notre
faible échelle de montrer qu'on pouvait
essayer de réhabiliter un peu la
politique en prouvant justement que la
politique doit surtout pas devenir un
métier de cuisson avait encore une autre
anomalie c'est qu'on se présenter à une
fonction on propose d'abolir est ce que
nous on n'est pas d'accord avec le
régime présidentiel ne pense que dans le
cadre de la 5ème république
c'est un pouvoir exorbitant qui fait
qu'un seul type aujourd'hui à comme le
pouvoir d'appuyer sur un bouton
nucléaire ce qui est quand même
vachement rassurant quand on voit la
gueule de certains autres candidats
et quand on sait que le pen arrive au
deuxième tour des élections
présidentielles par exemple c'était
risqué ça a payé vous y croyez au début
quand vous l'avez vu arriver besancenot
franchement non mais il est sympa mais
il s'est bien gardé
oui mais franchement pour l'amateur y
voit toutes ces grandes écoles vous
trouvez qu'on fasse un pas sérieux
française du tout je trouve qu'il est
je suis très étonné qu'ils qu'il affirme
qu'il faut pas être professionnel en
politique quand je vais dans un hôpital
où quand je vais je vais pas en
éducation nationale en chirurgie on j'ai
besoin d'être rassurés par un vrai
professionnel je ne trouve pas sympa je
le trouvais pas sa principale qualité sa
principale qualité c'est d'être vrai
faire croire qu'il est vrai ouais
à ce moment là il serait très habile et
moi à chaque fois je les ai vus passer
je me suis dit si je pensais pas ce que
je pense après tout je voterai peut-être
pour lui mais je ne voterai jamais pour
lui vu ce que je pense revivez je veux
dire c'est une question de génération
peut-être que si jamais votre âge je
reviendrai en 68 j'étais dans la rue
alors est ce que cette révolution qui
doit abattre le capitalisme est ce qu
elle peut passer par les urnes
est ce que vous croyez qu'un jour il y
aura une majorité de gens qui diront en
france à 51% en tous les cas en veut
plus du capitalisme le cas idéal ce
serait effectivement une coalition
d'organisations du mouvement social de
partis politiques qui arriverait au
pouvoir pour défendre les intérêts de la
majorité de la population n'arrivera pas
et qui prendrait le pouvoir et qui
pourrait mener tranquillement sa
politique le problème c'est que l'on
trouve les exemples pas arriver puisque
la propagande capitaliste l'idéologie
capitaliste est tellement forte
il y aura jamais 51 % des gens qui
voteront contre le capitalisme et
comment elle peut marcher cette
révolution sur comment on pouvait y
arriver puisque ce ne sera pas par les
yeux ça peut être que par la violence ça
peut être que par une prise de pouvoir
par la force
non je crois que ce serait une
mobilisation sociale historique comme
manager lui en france par exemple
l'équivalent d'un 1936 d'un 68 d'un
décembre 95 qui réussirait c'est à dire
où les salariés du secteur privé
seraient aussi de la partie
et puis qui posera effectivement des
questions politiques parce que quand un
pays est bloqué économiquement c'est à
dire ceux qui produisent au quotidien
les biens les richesses décide de
s'arrêter et le problème c'est
d'organiser la société donc avec ou sans
révolutionnaire de toute façon il ya des
comités qui seront dans les usines dans
les quartiers c'est que ça passera plus
par une grève générale
je pense qu'une grève générale bien sûr
mais je veux dire il n'y a pas de besoin
en effet de comprendre ce que l'on ya un
truc qui se passe soit vous que ce soir
let
on vous voit vous nous parlez toujours
de changer la société mais enfin bon par
les urnes on voit bien que ça va pas se
passer puisque vous êtes dans des
chiffres qui sont quand même inférieur à
5%
électorale donc on essaie de comprendre
comment ça pourrait se passer ça on vous
en parle jamais en fait on vous dit pas
pardon imaginez que cette révolution ait
réussi est-ce que les gens qui votent
pour vous ça de ce que vous ferez quand
vous serez au pouvoir qu est-ce que
finalement il aurait le pouvoir de nous
contrôler puis surtout on serait pas
tout seul au pays sauf alors on va
prendre des exemples est ce que vous
allez ray est attisée l'économie par
exemple de ce que vous avez même
renationaliser par une on n'est pas les
rois de la nationalisation à tous crins
tenant plus je suis trop bien placé pour
le savoir à la poste complète dans une
entreprise nationale et nationaliser ou
ou autres être parfaitement exploité
l'intérêt de cette entreprise est ce que
vous retireriez l'éventail des salaires
c'est-à-dire vous dites que vous n'avez
pas tort qu'en france un pdg gagne 500
fois le smic en fait il y en a en tous
les cas
est-ce que vous allez resserré
l'éventail des salaires en répartir est
différemment les richesses bien entendu
de façon il y aurait comme un éventail
heures comme des gens qui gagnent un peu
plus que les autres mais je veux dire la
décision les noirs ce qui va se passer
non mais la discussion qui intéresse la
dce la survie humaine sur le projet de
société clé en main elle n'existe pas
parce que c'est l'autre l'autre
peut-être bilan du stalinisme c'est
d'essayer de faire croire que les
révolutionnaires on va forcément
approché sociétés clés en main ligne à
ligne à proposer bah non c'est pas le
cas c'est pas le cas parce qu'il y ait
fait aucune référence
non faut faire confiance en nous mêmes
on est tous pour la majorité de la
population aura par exemple est-ce que
la réduction du temps de travail
ce sera combien ils imaginent ce lié au
pouvoir ou vos idées soit au pouvoir
c'est 32 heures 30 heure 25 heures 20
heures sur mer et ben ça sera calculé en
fonction des demandes de la société
c'est-à-dire on calculera le temps de
travail pour que tout le monde a un job
c'est à dire qu'on travaillera tous en
travaillant moins c'est à dire que ceux
qui sont interdits à l'intérieur pour
enfin travailler dans des conditions
plus décentes et y aura pas comme c'est
le cas actuellement des personnes qui
sont obligées de galérer au jour le jour
donc on sent un emploi soit dans des
petits boulots précaires pays pareil
avec une répartition égalitaire des
richesses mais il y avait quand même des
je dirais prenait un peu prenons par
exemple notre notre métier on ne peut
pas travailler deux par semaine 35
heures c'est impossible si on
comptabilise le nombre d'heures de
travail
on dépasse sa de de deux ou trois fois
sinon peut pas faire ce métier on est
éjecté mais alors comment vram
aucun problème là dessus je vous propose
pas quelque chose de centraliser ce que
je vous propose c'est un autre
fonctionnement où précisément chacun
dans sa branche choisira est absolument
et chacun adaptera nous notre projet de
société c'est faire passer les besoins
avant les profits ça veut dire que on
organise la société en fonction des
demandes mais des demandes réelles y
compris des demandes au travail parce
que pour moi faire la révolution ces
victimes ont changé notre vie au travail
parce que je pense qu'en gros il n'y a
pas mieux placé que la majorité de la
population pour savoir quels sont ses
besoins et comment on peut les
satisfaire
y compris au boulot quelle que soit la
branche là il y en a dans en 68 jeux
vous n'étiez pas là mais moi j'ai gueulé
là et je vous assure que c'est un peu
malléable mais disons que c'était à peu
près le même raisonnement du fond du
coeur ils sont descendus on est
descendus dans la rue il ya eu des morts
on s'est fait tuer enlever tabasser de
tous trente ans après ceux qui étaient
de ma génération se sont retrouvés au
pouvoir pourquoi n'ont ils pas pu
réaliser leur rêve peut-être tout
simplement parce que il ya 68 a pas eu
l'élan et la porte et qu'elle aurait
voulu avoir
parce qu'il manquait quelque chose
effectivement à 68 mais moins de toute
façon ce que je sais c'est que c'est une
autre histoire pour moi c'est une autre
histoire c'est notre génération de la
tessellation
non mais c'est c'est assez drôle parce
que vous lui dites mais mon pauvre gars
nous on a essayé de le faire ça pas
marché alors que je peux vous rassurer
c'est un discours que j'entends depuis
quelques temps je suis rentré en
politique d'ailleurs quand j'ai commencé
on a commencé à m'expliquer ça on a
commencé à m'expliquer que notamment en
bas dans les organisations qui sont
celles de la gauche plurielle
aujourd'hui il faut être un peu
responsable que tout ça était tentée
espérer ben moi je continue à avoir
l'espoir l'enthousiasmé je vois pas
pourquoi j'arrêterais parce que je
voudrais seattle h&m à porto allègre et
cette année en france parce que le
sommet du g8 aura lieu ici eh ben il y
aura encore des dizaines de milliers de
jeunes qui vont descendre dans la rue
qui vont interpeller cette gauche qui
continue olivier olivier qui leur dira
bottinelli dans comment on peut faire
pour changer les agissements de vos
idées soit au pouvoir augmentation de la
durée des congés payés oui oui mais non
même la discussion
mais évidemment
moi j'ai pas voté pour vous des jeux
quelque 1 jour 11 français mais parce
qu'on bosse vous avez pas les moins
besoin de congé parce que vous n'avez
pas les bonnes filles bon vous avez pas
les bonnes fiches parce que les bonnes
fiches n'est pas de me demander
dites moi quel est votre société est en
gros je voterai pour vous parce que
c'est pas mon idée de la politique on
idée d'alors lui tire un peu sur la
politique c'est quand ça comment on fait
pour changer le monde
oui discutons-en si vous me demandez ce
en voilà un truc clé en main le budget
un jour je ne râle pas d'argent là pour
le moment est-ce que légalisation du
cannabis oui oui on va le changer le
monde alors déjà l'autorisation des rave
parties je dis ça pour lui
normand et qu'on les laisse tranquilles
et qu'on aille pas faire croire qu'on va
chasser les théories alors vous êtes
contre vous êtes contre les paradis
fiscaux
1 est ce que vous pensez à l'annexion de
monaco et au renversement des grimaldi
mais que va devenir parent on va faire
péter les journalistes les vrais gens
on est d'accord dans tout ça c'est de
bell dans sa saison de belle et bonne
idée on est d'accord évidemment on peut
être que d'accord avec ça les gens vont
choisir vont être plus heureux ils vont
moins de travail et les salaires vont
être mieux réparti mais ceux qui sont
pas d'accord avec ça est-ce que ils
iront en prison bien entendu il ya des
blindés soviétiques qui sont venus
derrière moi je continue à manger les
enfants
bien sûr que non mais je veux dire la
discussion a pas de sens
la discussion a pas de sens le problème
qui se pose aujourd'hui s'ils voulaient
discuter de ce qui peut intéresser par
exemple aujourd'hui des dizaines de
milliers de jeunes c'est de savoir si
changer la société c'est encore possible
parce que à l'échelle de ce qui s'est
passé pendant un siècle
c'est l'idée même qu'on pouvait changer
le monde qui était effectivement
complètement discréditée soit parce que
c'est trop romantique soit parce que
c'est trop utopiste
soit parce que ça amène forcément à
quelque chose qui fera fuir les capitaux
c'est ça qu'on essaie de nous faire
croire aujourd'hui il ya quelque chose
qui avec ou sans nous est en train de
redémarrer comme demande
le problème c'est de savoir si oui ou
non peut réhabiliter le goût de changer
le monde le goût de la révolution et
pour moi la révolution c'est tout le
contraire de la destruction
c'est au contraire de la violence
gratuite c'est pas une flaque de sang à
chaque coin de rue c'est pas des
tribunaux militaires qui sont présents
ou des prisons partout la révolution
pour moi c'est la construction la
construction d'autres choses d'une autre
société
alors pour novembre c'est pas vous qui
êtes au pouvoir c'est pas vos idées
c'est chirac raffarin vous l'aviez
promis une rentrée sociale un petit peu
agitée c'est cool là pour le moment je
n'aurais pas promis à moi tout seul on
publie pas dans le marc de café stress
et que eux ont la trouille de sa eu
leurs angoisses et décembre 95 et 1
nouvelles manifestations contre le plan
juppé dont ils le cachent un peu en
espérant que ça redémarre pas je crois
qu'il ya tous les ingrédients d'abord
pour que les gens soient écoeuré dégoûté
et révolté et puis surtout je crois que
la droite à toutes les bonnes raisons
d'avoir la trouille pour la classe
ouvrière
quelles que soient ses défauts il aurait
mieux valu que je spa soit président non
ils étaient trois il était premier
ministre avant et je crois que
malheureusement ça n'a pas changé grand
chose
olivier besancenot est ce que vous ne
regrettez pas d'avoir été de ceux qui
ont fait battre jeu ce pas non parce que
je fais pas du tout partie de ce qu'on
s'est battus jospin j'ai pas empêché les
organisations de la gauche plurielle qui
était quatre ou cinq de présenter une
candidature unique par exemple
et d'ailleurs je crois que même lionel
jospin ne nous a jamais pointé du doigt
l'extrême gauche parce qu'il savait
qu'on avait des désaccords politiques
avec lui qu'on a fait entendre pendant
cinq ans de gestion de la gauche
plurielle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant jean pierre
gaillard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors vous êtes jean pierre gaillard à
la bourse que gillot pétré fut à la
météo ce que thierry roland est au foot
est vraiment maintenant une icône
médiatique on pourrait dire que le héros
des marchés vous êtes la voix du cac 40
et d'ailleurs les guignols vous en
immortalisé france inter france info lci
combien de direct en une journée une
vingtaine sur un faux cap sur inter et
neuf sur lci jean pierre gaillard au vu
du scandale enron est ce que vous croyez
encore à ce que vous communiquez wii
devrait plus y croyait plus mais vous
arrivez vous de conseiller l'achat
d'actions en vivant dit par exemple
non mais j'ai jamais conseillé d'acheter
une action particulière je fais faire
aux professionnels je le fais peur aux
autres par interviews interposées les
dents dans votre portefeuille d'actions
il ya du vivant dit il ya de l'alcatel
je crois c'est encore pire je vous dis
je prends ma vie je crois parce que j'ai
j'ai effectivement un portefeuille
d'actions parce que ça doit se voir mais
je crois pas aux opus signé qui goûte
pas sa cuisine seulement pour des
réactions des raisons déontologiques et
de tranquillité vis-à-vis de la cob
c'est un compte que je fais qui kg reste
un compte géré par un professionnel
c'est parce que vous avez comme action
ah non pas vraiment non non vous assure
ça cerveau à paroles tout fout l'camp
est ce que pensait que la bourse va
remonter à partir de la semaine
prochaine ce que l'armée annonce
je crois qu'il y en a pour un bon moment
un savez ça va dépendre de l'arrêt de la
croissance économique
et plus ça va plus les économistes en
est encore vu cet après-midi pense pas
qu'il y aura vraiment de gros démarrage
il n'y a pas d'accident encore en cours
de route avant 2004 2004 un petit moment
on va pas descendre jusqu'à 2004 la
bouffe ça va être des des hauts et des
bas jusque là croissance sera inférieure
à 3% l'année prochaine
ah oui d'après en europe
les gens que je vois c'est pour moi les
économistes que je vois pense plutôt un
ennemi et peut-être deux pour la photo
dès mais comment il va faire raffarin ah
bah comment il va faire et c'est ce
qu'il a promis à tout le monde c'est
effectivement un énorme problème je
reconnais qu'ils n'ont pas de sens il ya
une dissolution à la veille de la
reprise à la veille de la reprise et on
revient en pleine un plein moments
difficiles avec avec des affaires
lourdes
il va faire comme france télécom unis
sont quand même pas pour grand chose
une affaire des affaires lourdes il ya
le déficit de la poste aussi des
affaires lourdes les attentions
ils étaient six mille sept cents matches
dans ma carrière un coup trop c'est
beaucoup beaucoup mais en parlant du
déficit de france télécom on rigole mais
c'est plus que l'impôt sur le revenu je
crois que 5,2 fois le budget de la
défense
ça va être comme le crédit lyonnais
c'est les français qui vont payer aussi
vous qui voulez vous qu'ils paient il
faudra bien payer je sais pas de quelle
façon bientôt il va falloir ces gamins
sens et ça je veux pas donner raison à
besançon ou enfin il ya ceux qui
marchent bien
ça s'appelle les ptt tout va très bien 1
et on le privatise à moitié on le donne
à un mec qui ruine la sphère après c'est
nous qui payons ce que ça non c'est
peut-être parce qu'on la privatiser qu'à
moitié justement et même sûrement en
grande bretagne par exemple ils ont
privatisé les trains jamais autant
d'accidents
il avait pris 1 c'est vrai ils devront
leur a peut-être donné un matériel qui
était pas terrible non plus à la rue air
france à être privatisées
ah oui ça je crois que c'est parti c'est
vraiment et même des prochains à faire
bâton de l'état patron c'est moi je ne
trouve pas que c'est toujours terrible
je voulais vous dire que pour un vieux
soixante-huitard moi aussi je trouve un
peu on peut pas dire généralisée pour
dire que l'état patron c'est pas
terrible parce que s'ils n'avaient pas
l'état patron il y aurait pu la comédie
française depuis trois siècles aurait
pas le théâtre public et dieu sait si je
suis nourrie en ce moment par le théâtre
privé et si j'ai choisi donc la voie du
privé mais j'ai passé 20 ans dans le
service public au théâtre et et dieu
merci l'état est toujours là mais je
suis contre moi les excès une totalité
quelque part il faut effectivement il
doit rester d'aidé
des pans entiers qui doivent être aidés
qui doivent être menées par l'état très
probablement ce que j'aime passer le
partage le partage et à état et privés
tous les jours nous expliquer quand même
la tendance ce qui va aller ce qui va
pas aller alors je vous pose est comme
ça quelques questions est ce que vous
croyez que jean marie messier va toucher
ses indemnités sans avoir à sortir son
livre
bonne question je pense qu'il touchera
des indemnités sais pas si tout sera la
totalité on va attendre de voir le
monsieur fourre-tout nous donner sa
stratégie long terme
est ce que vous êtes favorable aux
licenciements dans les entreprises qui
font des bénéfices
on m'a toujours dit que alors faut pas
systématiser mais il ya des fois où il
vaut mieux se couper un bras qu d'y
passer en entier est il de vous demander
votre avis on pourra en discuter
longuement et parce que j'ai pas fait 68
effectivement mais pendant la campagne
est bien celui ci
mais j'ai rencontré les salariés
moulinex la campagne et je vois ce que
ça peut donner dans une région dans un
appartement qui est complètement broyé
quand on arrive à faire mais c'est
affreux
c'est vrai il faut éviter mais il faut
partir de ça faut partir d'abord de ça
parce que quand il ya des milliers
d'emplois avec des ouvrières aujourd'hui
qu'on pour certaines d'entre elles 45 50
ans qui font des cours de formation leur
dis qu'il faut absolument qu'elle
apprenne à se revendre parce qu'en plus
de leur job
elles ont perdu leur retraite eh ben ça
fait plus que mal au coeur ça nous
révolte
oui mais c'est ça nous révolte d'autant
plus que c'est ce que fait le marché de
l'électroménager pas on arrive le marché
de l'électroménager
d'après les dires de brillants
économistes à l'époque se portaient
plutôt pas mal et ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'il y avait des actionnaires
derrière tout ça les actionnaires
italiens compter les bénéfices de cette
boîte pendant des années et des années
quand tout allait bien et puis qu'on
décidé de rien réinsuffler quand il
s'agissait de sauver tout simplement une
région tout simplement la région cette
fusion donc donc pour moi c'est ça c'est
pas grave l'état on parlait de l'état et
ben oui l'état devra un moment décidé de
maintenir l'emploi comme une priorité
absolue dans la région avant des
actionnaires italiens l'avaient déjà
laissé se faire trop de mal c'est ça
faut pas laisser un plus vous pourriez
un fruit pourri re jusqu'au bout il ya
des moments où il faut effectivement
reprendre en main ce qui n'est pas
forcément d
des vagues cinq ans les guignols nous
font dire que grâce à un courage de
plans de licenciements le titre green
15% le lendemain le font dire à moi en
plus ça me hérisse assez drôle
un robinet que c'était le cas par
exemple s'est empêché de faire avant et
chemise et quand vous avez vu le soir
même au journal télévisé les ouvrières
de moulinex qui pleurait en apprenant la
fermeture de leur usine et que je les
comprends dans la rubrique d'appoint et
moi nous annoncer qu'il avait 20 %
supplémentaires des annonces nous
auraient pleuré récemment là j'ai un
truc qui va bien vous énerver est ce que
vous connaissez ce qu'on appelle lé vice
fiennes c'est à dire les valeurs salle
des titres qui sont insensibles à la
récession dire qu'on achète des fonds
qui investissent dans l'alcool le tabac
les armes le jeu et cela il marche très
bien ils ont fait plus 50 3% cette année
le principe fondateur c'est de dire que
les gens continuent à boire à fumer à
jouer quoi qu'il se passe sur le marché
vous les conseillez vous ces fonds il ya
également des fonds éthiques qui vont
dans l'autre sens à leur image
lorsqu on conseille pas systématiquement
évidemment- et on cote toujours c'est
vrai les sociétés de 10 à
l'aboutissement de la bourse
finalement pourquoi est-ce qu'on irait
investir dans des trucs qui se casse la
gueule alors que la drogue le jeu le
sexe les armes ça marche très bien non
car nous aimons les gens peuvent
investir là dedans et qui font plus 53%
pourquoi voulez vous qu'ils investissent
ailleurs est ce que finalement c'est pas
l'illustration de la perversion du
système ça sinon oui non je crois en ma
mort c'est pour ça quand même qu'on est
ce qu'on en fera nous promettre
aujourd'hui c'est l'avènement du
capitalisme éthique si j'ai bien compris
la même manière qu'on nous a promis
l'avènement du capitalisme populaire il
ya 4 ou 5 ans quand ont distribué des
millions d'actions à des millions
d'actionnaires conclu que des millions
paires d'yeux pour chialer comme vous
avez dû constater que non mais je sais
qu'un paquet de postiers qui l'avait
acheté bien sûr parce que c'est ça qu'on
a proposé à l'époque donc à l'époque on
nous a promis ça aujourd'hui c'est le
capitalisme éthique alors en plus c'est
chirac qui s'occupe de ça le 14 juillet
qui promet à ppda qui va mettre un peu
d'éthique dans le capitalisme
déjà que la tâche était classé chirac
qui s'en occupe
on vient barrer mais dans tous les cas
ce qu'on pourrait peut-être changer un
jour c'est que plutôt que de nous faire
des rubriques économique le soir vous
nous annonciez à la fin de chaque
journal télévisé dans tel quartier on a
construite en crèche temps de logements
temps d'hôpitaux temps d'école et bah
c'est pour ça que ce n'est pas moi ça
résume jean-pierre il ya un truc je vous
demander avant de terminer quand je vous
vois là parce que je regarde assez
souvent lci je vous vois arriver il ya
des fois quand la bourse est en chute
mais alors vous arrive et on dirait que
vous avez perdu père et mère avez vous
êtes lent au bord des larmes
alors vous arrivez vous faites
aujourd'hui ça paraît quand même ce
qu'elle plus avoir à wels or le cac ride
en baisse et mais c'est de la comédie
il va me dire que je suis comme
franchement c'est de la commune vous
êtes vraiment parce que si vous êtes
flipper à ce point là par la baisse du
cac 40 je crois c'est pas grave je vous
assure qu'en ce moment non suis pas
d'accord avec vous c'est en ce moment sa
figure que ça prend devient franchement
préoccupante
une crise comme celle là ça laisse des
séquelles
vous le disiez sur un plan d'un nouveau
gouvernement qui arrive qui va sur des
comment il va réaliser avec une
croissance qui ne revient pas avec des
actions qui suit avec des troupes sur
france télécom avec des trous un petit
peu partout c'est cette vous voulez y
avoir des cdc sur en plus il ya
également toujours ce risque de guerre
qui plane au dessus nous qui nous fait
rien que le rite rien que d'en parler
qui fait monter le pétrole mais ce qui
en dit si ça va mal de pétrole va monter
et avec un mp3 l'a30 doral 1,30 dollar
le baril chez nous il a pris sa
croissance se passait il va nous [ __ ]
le bourdon merci d'être venus en tous
les cas
rien sur france info et je reprends
charter monsieur
[Musique]
m
et
key
et maintenant
[Musique]
april
a mende et magna
voici neige de la présence
[Musique]
inès marie-laëtitia églantine de
seignard de la fressange aujourd'hui
madame inez d'urso alors vous avez été
inès le premier mannequin star en france
bien avant la mode et la médiatisation
des top models vous était aussi le
premier mannequin qui parle parce qu'il
a surpris tout le monde à l'époque
votre physique androgyne chic a marqué
les années 80
et si on vous voit moins aujourd'hui les
français n'ont pas oublié celle qui fut
leur mariage à 45 ans vous vous décider
enfin à parler dans un livre qui
s'appelle profession mannequin et c'est
chez hachette littérature avec marianne
mair
et voilà alors votre vie commence dans
un univers très proustien d'ailleurs le
livre commence en disant longtemps je me
suis habillé de bonheur on croit
toujours que sa famille est particulière
la mienne l'est vraiment dites vous mes
parents ne s'occupait pas beaucoup de
nous il allait se promener dans leur
triomphe décapotable rose alors ça
serait extraordinaire
ça peut tenir des positions dans les
couloirs ça qui va pouvoir apprécier non
non c'est très apprécié votre mère
sud-américaine brune cheveux longs corps
parfait et une en france le père rêveur
farfelu dernier des trois garçons du
marquis paul de la fressange héros de la
guerre de 14-18 et de la fille du
banquier de lazard en c'était l'époque
où les jeunes nobles épousé des
héritières de la banque
est-ce que tu as eu bel ami wayne en
effet c est en fait
bah ouais je sais c'est comme ça mariage
entre un catholique donc issu d'une
famille de croiser du 12e siècle est
l'une des femmes les plus riches de
france à l'époque
alors commence très fort en la ville à
grands pas partout black
intentionnellement ss à moulins moulin
dans les yvelines par moulin de 26
pièces pour m il y avait une roue avec
de l'eau en dessous et bah oui mais à
part ça c'était assez vaste
ouais c'était grand les 20 hectares
autour ouais il faut ça pour autant de
pieds
ça va du terrain autour autrement studio
ballon est alors à l'école inès l'école
communale septième victime des autres
des autres enfants
moi non j'étais super timide et puis et
puis gentil et tout alors on peut penser
que j'étais niaise quoi j'étais vraiment
malheureuse est alors du coup mes
parents ont cherché enfin ma famille à
chercher une autre école pas loin c'est
à la campagne en avait pas vraiment
beaucoup
et alors il y avait une école privée de
garçons il y avait que des garçons et et
l'école m'a acceptée comme unique fille
est l'unique externe à jouer au foot
et puis donc moi j'étais obligé de jouer
au foot
généralement de mettet goal com toute
façon il marquait pas beaucoup de buts
ça allait et puis je devais jouer à la
balle au prisonnier
et puis au bia et maintenant quand je le
raconte sa part extraordinaire seul au
milieu de 250 bonhomme et puis il y en
avait un qui m'avait écrit une lettre en
me disant tu es la plus belle de l'école
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'étais cool me sers tu sais
j'écoute toujours alors ils naissent une
enfance heureuse mais aucun repas pris
avec vos parents n'ai pas le souvenir
d'un prix des repas à quatre avec votre
frère et vos parents parce que vos
parents étaient étaient absents très
souvent et vous avez passé votre enfance
avec le chef avec la femme de ménage
jardinier le métayer la nounou vous été
élevé avec les domestiques en fait
bah ouais mais alors avant je racontais
pas tout ça parce que ça me paraissait
très marie chantal et snobinard avec
besancenot a pas de problème mp avant
j'avais un petit peu honte quoi je
racontais pas à ça et tout que j'étais
hague le chef maître d'hôtel jardinier
la femme d indignés le gardien mais il y
avait une ambiance formidable à cuisine
c'est pas une pauvre petite fille riche
petit gérer
l'envié des parents charmant poétique
très bohème un pas du tout bm alors chez
vous ils naissent rien n'était interdit
on pouvait tout dire c'est pas
angoissant quand on est tout petit comme
ça ne pas avoir de limites
si tu as compris docteur vous avez
compris non c'est vraiment c'est vrai
c'est qu'il faut avoir un tout petit peu
d'autorité et puis c'est rassurant pour
les enfants les habitudes des choses le
laxisme ou la permissivité et tout ça
fait un petit peu peur mais de tout dire
oui c'est pas dans les familles on dit
ou pense par le plus noir
c'est pas mal ça allait bien pouvoir
était dans la mode mais quand même quand
même qu'un qui parle en même temps donc
oui c'est la seule à son bac elle l'a
eue plus un plus un c'est bien et ouais
moi plus de jetons mannequin
alors le dire c'est les vacances une
petite virée
les vacances c'est terrible c'est la
première émission télévisée je fais oui
et alors tout d'un coup avec tout ce que
tu racontes
les gens sont super sympas jusqu'à
présent avec moi dans la rue oui mais là
relate ou non mais je sais ça tire les
larmes c'est des vacances au royal à
deauville
anwar est un des six fils ici il faut
préciser que c'est un très grand hôtel
l'hôtel voilà les parents n'étaient pas
là bas j'avais juste la grande y avait
juste à grand-mère la dame de compagnie
lanners et le chauffeur il arrive et se
faisait remarquer en plus des amplitudes
cinq personnes accros au but devant cas
c'était les vacances donc à deauville et
la grand-mère était jamais là parce
qu'elle passait son temps casino aux
courses dans les dîners et une fois de
plus la pauvre inez se retrouver avec le
maître d'hôtel mais c'était pas j'espère
maintenant parce que maintenant mais
c'était pas forcé le petit déjeuner il
avait il avait un monte charge et où il
prépare et les petits déjeuners tout ça
partait en l'aider à faire les plateaux
c'est pas genre on est abandonné mais
j'aimais mais qu'il était super sympa
c'était des domestiques à payer à
olivier travail à faire à l'aise non
enfin il a l'air de dire la pauvre elle
était abandonnée tournoi c'est que juste
c'était particulier n'était pas triste
en fait non plus quoique quand les camps
les parents louer la maison dans les
vignes à saint tropez vous étiez dans un
petit hôtel avec votre frère quand même
ouais visiter un petit cabanon comme ça
hein
ouais c'est années 70 comme ça et nous
on était cassée dans la nôtre petit
hôtel c'était un peu étonnant mais ça
s'appelait l'hégire elle et c'était
super sympathique voyez ses parents la
plage uniquement c'est terrible l'hiver
fin
l'hiver pareil non mais elle pleure pas
d'excès lorsque l'hiver c'était terrible
aussi les parents pas ce qu'ils nomment
dis pas que ça va ce qui est léger
d'aller inscrire sa grand mal à megève
au mont d'arbois nokia mais quelle
horreur à l'hôtel du monde arabe mais
pas du tout il est vachement bien non
alors ça je le dis une fois encore tout
à fait voir monsieur vous calmer ses
bouquins et vachement bien je le dis et
en plus tu me lève lui ce qui m'épate
c'est que tu l'as lu là parce que là je
sens qu'il a vraiment lu au début
j'avais même pris des notes
non ce qui vous faisait rêver jusqu'à
fin mars à ses habits trois ans mais
n'est pas au bout ma fille ça c'est tout
ça tu es fiche un peu du livre à la même
chose parce que partie franchement
d'accord encore des téléspectateurs oui
on me les ont fait ce qu'ils veulent
savoir à quel moment ça c'est sympa si
[Rires]
nous sommes encore là et qu aucun
n'avait d'ailleurs non en fait il
faisait rêver quand vous étiez enfant
c'était la vie des enfants du maître
d'hôtel patrick et sylvie qui habitait à
ruelle dans une hlm c'est vrai bah ouais
non mais c'est vrai quoi ils avaient des
voix devant on est à la campagne mais où
vous avez voisins en bas en haut et tout
on trouvait ça en trouvez ça beaucoup
plus rigolo et à peut-être eu tort
non pas du tout en vacances à romorantin
jour leur rêve absolu
hynes a pu aller en vacances à robot et
ben c'était top
et c'était top bar homo mais il avait
une barque et tout mais enfin bon moi tu
parlais beaucoup beaucoup avec ses
entretiens de marianne mais reste c'est
à dire c'est pas moi qui écrit le livre
j'ai eu une mire s est alors du coup moi
je parlais papotait papoter et il
fallait j'ai rien à vous racontez moi
c'est pas que c'est si passionnant que
ça alors elle notait et elle c'est elle
qui a choisi c'est sa faute
marianne mairesse n'est pas là pour dire
c'est pas moi qui écris le
ça n'est pas l'avis dit nesbitt oui
alors à l'époque inès vous rêvez de tout
sauf d'être mannequin je ne sais pas
ouais non à l'époque c'était super mal
vu quoi une fille qui voulait être
mannequin minette un peu bêta ouais
j'étais un peu poilu aussi ça toujours
sauf sur la tête
c'est à vous à raser les jambes un jour
oui ces poilus marquer ça non mais elle
a noté le gain en huit ans et médias non
mais ça va pas du tout juste et tout est
là et tout à coup et là tout à coup on y
arrive soudainement revers de fortune
qui est oui
obligé de gagner de l'argent ici et
voilà
et là on revient marc ollivier d'un seul
coup fait parti des travailleurs et les
travailleuses voit la fin du grand train
de vie don d'une certaine façon un peu
chauffé me suis mis à travailler surtout
parce que ça me gênait demander des sous
à mes parents quoi oui et puis et puis
en plus je pensais que j'allais faire
sans dilettante que je continuerai mes
histoires de m'aimer mais cours
d'histoire de l'art d'archéologie et que
j'allais faire ça comme ça un petit peu
quelques photos dans attendre pour avoir
des sous en fait je les fais 14 ans
j'allais gagner de l'argent il fallait
acheter un poêle godin mail pour le
moulin locaux d'achopper match au p 26
pièces avec un solde le docteur godin a
précédé avec les premiers cachets il
faisait vraiment froid la maison voilà
j'ai acheté un poêle godin mes parents
l'ont mis dans la cuisine alors je te
dis pas la chaleur
cette visite et après pour monter dans
les chambres d'allumettes un anorak et
des moonboots crois qu'elle a souffert
donc les photos commencent première
séance avec n'importe qui avec olivero
toscani cafés des campagnes benetton il
est allé ce bord mais moi je croyais
qu'il se moquait de moi un peu en fait
oui je crois qu'il se moquait de moi
mais il était quand même gentil mais une
phrase sur cette première séance de
photos qui est extraordinaire vous dites
c'est un peu étrange d'avoir à se mettre
tout de suite en petite culotte devant
des gens qu'on n'a jamais vus c'est vrai
que pour vous venant du milieu phrase
tellement belle et tellement bien je
crois que c'est marianne mairie les
débuts sont un peu difficiles et puis
tout d'un coup quelqu'un vous voit un
petit peu comme pour la com pour la
première fois et il pense que votre
différence en fait peut faire votre
succès c'est jean jacques picart
mais c'est quelqu'un d'important dans la
mode et qui n'est pas quelqu'un de connu
ce qui a fait votre succès in est ce
qu'on appelle le style inès c'est quoi
c'est d'arriver au bout du podium de
faire le clown de prendre une pause où
il y avait un défilé lanvin vous avez
pris un bus dans la tête
et ouais mais bon vous l'avez jouez vous
l'avez pas maintenant mais je n'ai pas
fait exprès j'ai pris vraiment le lustre
j'avais pas faire après comme si de rien
n'était alors que je voyais des étoiles
comme d'emprunter un comme ça c'est ça
que ce naturel ou d'un moment il ya tout
un tas de gens qui viennent vous voir
derrière des masses et rip était divine
parce que toi au moins tu souris et
péter naturel et humain comme dans la
rue on les écoute un peu et puis du
monde après toute façon je ne sais pas
faire quoi que ce soit d'autre
et puis en plus c'était une forme de
dérision 10 rebonds je suis mannequin je
ne suis pas vraiment la preuve si je
vous dis bonjour quand tu veux je prends
pas la peau en fait c'est un petit peu
renier ce qu'on est en train de faire
quoi c'est pas bien de faire ça c'est
pas bien mais elles ne font plus
maintenant et en 1983 inès vous signez
votre fameux contrat chanel avec karl
lagerfeld chanel
oui c'était karl lagerfeld qui dirige
échappé belle n'a été employé comme moi
mais il avait beaucoup poussé pour
compte s'ils ne comptera quoi l'amour
oui mais c'est grâce à lui
mais c'était pas j'étais pas son employé
c'est en exclu ouais pas facile non plus
âgés chanel pas facile surtout quand tu
gagnes 4000 vols par jour à 1 million de
francs pour les parents s'installent
fond c'est difficile mais c'est dur à
gérer
c'était non mais ce qui était
extrêmement d'arriver dans la boutique
et drogba je prends un sage
mon rêve c'était le rêve et un coup de
franc cette veste et puis tout d'un coup
cauchemar lave est arrivé là moi je suis
plus tranquille avant que je rentre
dedans maintenant ils font même de 38 à
ce business
tu es une vraie amie voilà donc génère l
époque vous devenez une grosse star
énorme star et les les gens croient que
c'est vous qui dessiné les collections
non c'est que les gens n'arrivent me
disait on aime beaucoup ce que vous
faites
je n'ai rien moi et puis oui non y avait
une confusion je recevais des lettres
qui avait marqué coco chanel 31 rue
cambon alors les jambes
l'obs arrivé chez moi en ce doux et
rennes et puis non si les gens aussi où
une dizaine des noms de parfum dans la
rue dénombre par fan de chez chanel
il me faisait comme si j'avais un
pourcentage donc ça a commencé un petit
peu à se dégrader avec karl lagarfeld
les relations à ce moment là non c'est à
dire que au bout d'un moment il ya eu
cette histoire de marianne dans les
maires de france ont décidé que je
pouvais être marianne et donc ça va
énerver calme ce nom oui les gars tu
devrais refusé vie comme ça la tête
comme ça dans tous les cas il s'est bien
vengé
il vous a fait défiler avec une seule
robe brodée de fleurs de lys ans il a
voulu me faire défiler avec une seule
robe brodée de fleurs de lis moi j'ai
dit non je trouve pas ça drôle et que je
le ferai pas m'a dit c'est ça ou rien ne
sera rien voilà
oui
c'est quoi ça veut dire quoi c'est en
éviction de chez chanel a retrouvé des
images c'est bon je t'ai fait jeter ya
la guerre fait derrière dans le bouquin
vous n'êtes pas vache avec du tout avec
lagerfeld je vois pas pourquoi on ayant
travaillé pendant sept ans avec
quelqu'un et en ayant dit que c'était
quelqu'un qui avait un énorme talent et
qui a effectivement un énorme talent si
tout d'un coup n'est plus vraiment
copains comme avant on va dire ballon
est finalement je sais pas s'il a
tellement de talent et dont il garde
il vous a quand même traité de même qu'à
vieillissant quoi mais il a tout dit
mais enfin c'est pas parce qu'il est dit
des vacheries qu'il faudrait en dire
né pendant une époque je me taisais
juste lui disait et v three et puis nous
pendant ce temps avec luigi on faisait
plein d'autres trucs
justement alors le problème c'est ça si
vous aviez rencontrer luigi et ça aussi
ça lui rendent jaloux car non vous étiez
moins à lui s'était pas vraiment fiancée
car la gare celle non plus longtemps a
précisé
d'accord papa il est très posé si il est
très possessif in health quand même non
je tiens plus la chine est non mais non
peut-être qu'il a dû sentir un peu
abandonné la deuxième va moins
s'intéresser au truc est tous là
peut-être fait une petite parano il a dû
penser bon même plus que ça puisque les
fold amoureuse et tout peut-être que là
maintenant elle va pas s'intéresser
vraiment à ce qu'elle sait la malice
comme se sentir trahis
moi je comprends maintenant j'ai appris
après tant d'années que les jambes et
réagissent souvent par leur peur vous
laisse pas les miennes à l'époque
bah ouais des trains non c'est vrai sur
un belle voire mieux sur ce mois il
savait pas du tout à quel point je
tenais à lui c'est sûr dans ce soir la
bête là du coup il a perdu 57 kg et
chaque fois qu'ils voyaient civils y ont
fait du 38 tous les deux tout ce qu'il
trouvait la vidéo cette fois non l ai
dit comment vas tu es filles photo dr
après chanel en annulation encore placé
en mer dont l'assureur parce que vous
montez votre propre maison de stylisme
et en fait vous vendez votre nom ouais
et un jour vous dessinez en dehors de ce
que vous faites pour les jantes et les
financer votre boîte vous dessinez un
petit pilulier
pour la jouvence de l'abbé soury et vous
signez ce petit pilulier inès de la
fressange ou c'est mon en fait comme ses
sambas de pastor et voilà oui
virée dans la première fois concurrence
déloyale combien de bouquins je pourrais
revenir et j'aurais pris en fromage
implante des boomers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouai c'est trop bien des grandes banques
qui ont comme un des mecs qui vont en
irak ont à voir ça c'est génial mais
devrait faire ça aux anniversaires des
genres moment-là pas me tuer ensuite en
commun
nous
c'est bien c'est bien mais vous le
méritez différence
donc voilà donc après ça voilà après
vous vous retrouvez vous êtes plus votre
nom dont pouvaient pu bosser je peut
plus exercer mon métier non c'est
insensé
mais comment comment vous faites vous
travaillé de façon occulte alors non
ouais parfois et puis je suis consultant
avec par exemple des présentateurs télé
je dis que mes vestes noires
[Rires]
sérieusement inès toute votre vie vous
ne pourrez plus jamais utiliser votre
nom pour bah ça dépend dans quelle
catégorie les produits pharmaceutiques
par exemple je peux voilà c'est ce qu'on
m'a demandé voka a expliqué aux
prud'hommes c'est pour ça que vous êtes
retourné sur les podiums pour défiler
parce que finalement ça c'est non parce
que comme j'essaie d'expliquer dans ce
livre on choisit pas d'être mannequin on
ne devient pas ce que les gens vous
demandent de l'être on peut pas avoir
une vocation
magnéto serge
à douala à douala
[Musique]
radio à l'école
massey un moment
[Musique]
aux pays bas les coeurs
ap tiger
[Musique]
un pétale
à douala
[Musique]
j'étais au défilé gaultier en janvier
dernier c'est moi qui me suis roulé par
terre après maintenant on fait des
bilans d'interviews donc inez bilan de
cette interview ça va vous êtes contente
de voir m
non j'avais tellement les pétoches avant
d'arriver je me suis dit même bien tes
sado maso alors cette époque là c'est
fini
j'avais peur de la question vérité c'est
qu'ils donnent la mauvaise mine
ces besoins
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chez hachette littératures mesdames
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on continue avec tout le monde s'en mêle
d'abord rectificatif contrairement à ce
qui a été annoncé par un invité dans
tout le monde en parle du 7 septembre
serge cardu le sosie de michel sardou
n'est pas en prison
c'est un autre sosie de michel sardou
authentique escrocs celui là qui est en
prison dont acte à part ça beaucoup de
mails en réponse à notre concours
que s'est il passé le 4 septembre à par
l'anniversaire de lou doillon pourquoi
toutes les rues s'appelle rue du 4
septembre
est ce que vous le savez vous mais je
crois qu'il ya eu un massacre au moment
de la commune
vous n'êtes pas plus fort que gérard
longuet lui il a été ministre culture
and is éducation nationale non c'est la
chute du second empire donc la déchéance
de napoléon iii
après ce don et la programmation de la
troisième république
et bien tant mieux ça me fait plaisir de
s'affaiblir a passé 4 septembre c'est le
risque quand on a su que je te dise
voilà beaucoup de mails pour michaël
blanc qui n'a pas été libérés pour la
fête nationale indonésienne du 17 août
nous recevrons d'ailleurs la semaine
prochaine une journaliste qui vient de
passer dix jours avec lui à bali voilà
michaël blanc en prison à perpétuité
imbali on passe à reporter sans
frontières 114 mon avis sont
actuellement en prison uniquement pour
avoir exercé leur métier
c'est le cas de grigory pasko qui a
révélé que l'armée russe déversé des
déchets radioactifs en mer du japon
ça lui a valu quatre ans de prison à
vladivostok et il voit ses proches qu
une fois tous les trois mois reporters
sans frontières est de grigory pasko et
si vous voulez et des reporters sans
frontières vous pouvez acheter l'album
photos de yann arthus bertrand pour la
liberté de la presse voilà on passe aux
nouvelles de l'émission baffie beaucoup
de gens me demandent où est passée
laurent baffie il termine son film était
que son film sera fini
viendra avec nous ici comme avant thalia
titia j'ai dit qu'elle reviendrait si
vous êtes sages donc soyez sages en
attendant beaucoup de messages pour
bulli
à part ça il ya les pour et contre
bigard les pour et contre bové pareil
pour la troupe de stephano en tous les
cas merci pour vos conseils merci pour
vos critiques
je lis tous les mails voilà tout
m'envoyer je les lis et alors j'ai gardé
pour la fin le mail d'agostino sferrazza
guy dit je regarde l'émission ce soir et
je m'aperçois thierry que depuis presque
vingt ans nous nous voyons tous les
samedis
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant alice evans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien alors on commence tout de suite
avec une question d'un téléspectateur
par mal puisque maintenant les
téléspectateurs peuvent poser des
questions aux invités de l'émission la
liste et sur le site de tout le monde en
parle depuis une semaine
alors est ce que le fait d'avoir
commencé votre carrière alice evans chez
ab prod dans la série et lisa top model
avec julien courbet n'a pas pénalisé la
suite de votre carrière
je ne pense pas vous laisser savoir ce
que j'aurais fait si je n'avais pas fait
et vise à terme être modèle avec julien
courbet alors une question maintenant un
mail de thierry ardisson
alice evans comment vivez-vous votre
séparation d'avec olivier picasso
je pensais que vous allez attendre un
petit peu avant de poser ses questions
mais non pas du tout pas du tout
d'accord
[Musique]
ban a été le seul que j'ai des problèmes
viktor bout est prête à répondre j'ai
pas répond oui mais je donne des temps
pour réfléchir maintenant j'ai bien
réfléchi je vis ça très mal comme toute
séparation c'est très dur ou de vie huit
ans de vie commune
on est très amis et voilà parfois la vie
n'est pas facile
et les choses ne vont pas comment
voudrait et c'était le cas et je pense à
lui tous les jours et je la pâte très
très souvent j'ai fait ici j'ai fait la
boulette j'ai cassé l'ambiance non
bompard d'autres choses bah oui on va
parler du nouveau film de jean marie
poiré où vous cherchez vous cherchez un
milliardaire
je cherche un milliardaire je suis
convaincu qu'il va m'emmener tout ce que
je cherche c'est à dire la célébrité
instantanée comme les gens par exemple
qui vont dans des lofts ou qui sortent
avec des gens connus
sauf qu'il n'est pas ce que je pensais
qu'il était et en plus il est marié
donc je m'énerve et l'histoire prend sa
suite
ça s'appelle ma femme s'appelle maurice
est une pièce qui a eu énormément de
succès à paris les saisons dernières
chevallier laspalès s'était joué très
longtemps à marignier entre autres et ça
s'est passé comment de tournage je
m'arrête à un passionné formidable qui
connaît tellement bien le cinéma qu'on
n'a pas besoin de se poser des questions
techniques
il sait exactement ce qu'il veut même
temps on a beaucoup collaboré ensemble
j'ai vraiment pris mon pied pendant
quatre mois c'était formidable
je n'ai pas encore vu le film ouais
c'est un film de jean marie poiré donc
avec chevallier laspalès qui reprenait
le rôle qu i télé sur scène vous une
pléiade d'acteurs est acquis à martin
lamotte et anémone gosse auto finalement
il aimait jouer dans un big band
extrêmement grand stéphane on prend
virginie lemoine du verger lemoine voilà
je crois qu'on a fait le tour et je
crois ouais ça va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble manitou
[Musique]
où le charme
m
[Musique]
je ne supporte plus il n'a jamais été
l'amant de personne même pas nous
ne semblait pas insatisfait tu vois
plutôt quelque chose dans le genre où la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toute petite [ __ ] vous avez des termites
in mais on est dessus
il a démonté fille ce côté là je fais
pas très emmanuelle béart
c'est ma femme c'est sûr que c'est pas
sharon stone
[Musique]
aboulaye
ma femme s'appelle maurice no kill j'en
arrive poirel à mes yeux
j'en arrive pas et qui revient à ses
premières amours c'était bien
l'adaptation au cinéma de pièces de
théâtre c'est ce qui les fait déjà deux
fois de suite au départ voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
kabré du boudin
c'est le bonheur olivier besancenot vous
allez nous quitte et merci d'être venus
merci à vous à bientôt avoir commis ces
abus
[Applaudissements]
key
et maintenant
[Musique]
voici philippe sollers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça va pas mal bien alors vous
dit philippe sollers monde aussi est
toujours le même les procureurs
ressortent les mêmes pièces on a
instruit les mêmes choses
pendant ce temps je travaille j'écris
des livres que mes détracteurs ne
prennent même plus la peine de lire
il essaie d'évacuer mes textes mais ils
sont toujours là et ils resteront voilà
donc avant de parler du cas sollers
on va parler du livre c'est un roman
c'est chez gallimard et ça s'appelle les
toiles des amants
43e livre compas et moi je compte alors
le pitch bail à un journaliste du jdd
christian sauvage qui vous conseillez
dimanche dernier de préparer votre pitch
pour l'émission de ce soir il avait
trouvé une phrase un livre entier sur la
jouissance d'exister alors ce livre en
même temps c'est page 53 du bouquin à un
livre entier sur la cuisse ans
d'existence c'est vrai qu'est ce que ça
veut dire à la plupart des livres
aujourd'hui des robes longues en a 600
700 800 qui paraissent de la rentrée
vous allez dans les librairies vous les
ouvrez et vous voyez qu'en effet le
drame est là la crise menace le
l'embarras et constant le désespoir et
la mélancolie progresse peut-être un
meurtre peut-être un viol
peut-être une petite histoire de
serial-killer peut-être un pédophile qui
se glisse sous les jambes de la france
d'en bas
peut-être quelque chose de dramatique
quelque chose voilà tout à coup j'ai
créé ali pour dire ah on va s'arrêter
on va écrire une histoire d'amour très
simple pour montrer deux personnages qui
sème donc y deviennent asociaux du même
coup et qui vont faire quoi mais rien
rien simplement éprouver la jouissance
d'exister alors c'est une compilation
des obsessions sur les siennes on l'a
beaucoup dit aussi la misogynie vous dit
les saints qui l'hébergeait j'en ai eu
ma claque ok moi je dis ça à tout le
monde trouve sa mise au vous dit ça tout
le monde ça génial
oui non mais c'est bien rien de vert
d'apollinaire que j'aime beaucoup mais
je ne sais pas si oui vous avez réussi
ça vous je suppose j'espère pour vous
oui je crois que oui je souhaite dans ma
maison une femme ayant sa raison oui oui
mais ce sauf que je pense que la raison
d'une femme c'est justement d'avoir de
la déraison
houle a bien raison d'une femme ce
serait d'avoir enfin de la région à la
paix les singles et merci j'ai eu ma
claque en insistant un peu on finit par
s'apercevoir qu'elles le sont toutes
alors donc la misogynie
l'exhibitionnisme on peut aussi se
montrer pour mieux se cacher on finit
par ne plus voir quelqu'un c'est vrai ça
qu'on voit tout le temps les surexposé
sont invisibles
oui tas d'argile ardisson l'inconnu bah
voila voila connu c'est la personne ne
soupçonne que c'est ça on peut on peut
se cacher en plage ou sur les spots mais
je crois un poil de sec ce normal 1 on
est passé du péché à la viande vous dit
en gros aujourd'hui on est passé du fait
que l'homme la sexualité on devrait
écrire aujourd'hui je crois comme que
nole écrivez vous savez la sexualité
avec deux aces à la sexualité c'est de
çà devient dans l'ennui profond
à partir du moment où ça devient presque
obligatoire il vaut mieux il vaudrait
mieux s'abstenir
je trouve ça vraiment je vais faire avec
les femmes au cinéma
c'est une tradition chez nous si les
moules l'humour aussi alors quand on
fait de l'humour vous prévenez à vous
dites vous prévenez que vous allez faire
de l'humour page 95
vous dites un moment d'humour à présent
oui ils vont traverser nécessite
honnêteté il vaudrait mieux préservés en
plus en plus parce que désormais
l'ironie l'ironie surtout devient
presque incompréhensible c'est vrai la
misogynie l'exhibitionnisme le sexe
l'humour et puis aussi le milieu
littéraire alors au sujet des critiques
à un moment mode vous dis tu crois
vraiment qu'il ne lise rien et vous vous
répondez pas grand chose quelques lignes
pour renforcer un préjugé négatif
je crois qu'on peut constater qu'en
effet de tourner il ya beaucoup de
livres et le bus que dans la lecture est
en train de s'affaiblir de plus en plus
je requiers neurologiquement un problème
c'est la télé ça non la télé fait partie
du truc
mais c'est dans cette c'est vraiment une
civilisation planétaire ou vraiment le
la lecture va devenir de plus en plus
rares c'est à dire que désormais
quelqu'un qui saura vraiment lire me
dire en profondeur on pourra l'exposer
comme un cas vous lisez des bouquins de
sollers de temps en temps j'ai trouvé ça
très porno dans l'esprit puisque dans la
dans la forme
oui je trouve que il a écrit une place à
part c'est un je trouve qu'il a paris il
a il a pas vieilli quoi il a il a l'air
d'avoir 20 ans il raconte toujours les
mêmes
les mêmes obsessions ça qui est beau je
trouve qu'il a beaucoup de charme
ils étaient accueillis comment la
l'étoile des amants c'est toujours la
même chose plutôt bien plutôt mal voilà
enfin tester fifty boullier être
l'élément perturbateur de la rentrée
s'était dit je vais être 11 septembre
éditorial ans a choqué alors l'attention
des gens vous êtes est érodée moi je
trouve ça bien voyez où on en est et
s'est dit ça c'est ironique chez lecoq
pour plaisanter et ils m'ont dit c'est
un des changes est obscène pour qui se
prend-il that et patata d'ailleurs j'ai
pas dit que c'était des avions qui
allait aller directement sur l'elysée où
la tour eiffel a pas d'écrit de sauveur
ça peut être un gaz virus
dites moi alors j'ai pas été tellement
l'élément perturbateur de la rentrée il
n'y a pas eu de vrai en septembre dit
rien les perturbateurs c'est plutôt les
mecs qu'au fond rose bonbon
il entrerait dans la légende john cornyn
et scories qui n'ont encore me voyez
attendais un peu soit d'accord je viens
juste d'arriver l'attention car en
parlant de jugement de la jouissance
d'exister c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
toujours cette impression comme ça
d'être bien de jouir de vous-même de
jouir de la situation etc
mais est-ce que c'est pas un peu
surjouée l'autre jour je vous ai vu dans
une émission de télévision sur canal +
qui s'appelle l'hyper show présenté par
frédéric beigbeder
je vois dans cette émission fait des
bonds avec doc gynéco vous chanter du
rap etc
vous avez cette jouissance d'exister
évidente et trois jours après dans le
journal vous dis que cette émission est
épouvantable c'est de la régression
infantile
ce jour-là vous jouiez la comédie
c'était pas une vraie jouissance
d'exister non c'est un plaisir de se
montrer pour wii pour faire de la
désinformation
j'ai d'ailleurs oublié complètement
cette émission les oublis en général
d'ailleurs
voulez vous en souvient celle là c'est
pas sûr des fois on forçait pas du tout
en revanche j'ai vu dans une émission
avec bernard tapie
aussi je suis pas prêt et là vous aviez
l'air vraiment de vous emmerder face à
tapis d'affaires erreurs y avait à côté
de moi une prostituée absolument chars
qui s'appelle claire cartonné retenez ce
nom
il prit absolument intelligent cap
défendu son métier on sait comment ça
s'est terminé
[Musique]
alors je les ai vus dans l'émission
guillaume durand campus je voulais fait
tout a rejoint oui et puis j'oublie
avez vous oublié mais alors là j'ai cru
que vous ressembliez ce soir là hervé
bazin je suis énervé bazin dans ses
pieds ne se souvient pas mais le prix
staline hervé bazile faisait peur oui
non pas du tout de voir si on s'est
retrouvé ensemble la mort hervé et mes
enfants mes enfants il sauf que vous
ressemblez au mois de la mène comme ça
ah oui ça toute fausse déjà là et puis
et puis c'est tout et puis c'est tout je
vais dire le titre du livre comme ça je
vais faire philippe sollers l'étoile des
amants chez gallimard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pas sur la liste du goncourt si à
mais de façon subliminale à ça me
rassure il faut savoir lire entre les
accords mon dossier est trop lourd pour
avoir le bon qu elle va vous faites
beaucoup de fait beaucoup de citations
dans ce ne sont pas des citations ce
sont des excitations la visite ce sont
des preuves sont belles réalisations ce
sont des prophètes beaucoup de citations
pourquoi ne sont pas sourcées vos
citations je veux que ce qu'on lise ce
que ça dit pas qui d'accord bois papier
vous êtes un tel amateurs de citations
que vous n'allez pas échappé philippe
sollers à l'interview citation
[Musique]
alors tout le monde peut jouer vous et
si vous ne trouvez pas les autres mon
avis la première c'est vous qui allez
trouver à vaincre sans péril on triomphe
sans gloire
ça c'est mon grand père qui s'appelait
cormeilles quand c'est trop c'est trop
picot fait pas attention jeu et la
réalité mais c'est quand même le seul
endroit où on peut se faire servir un
bon steak
ça pourrait être vous dis amen non à vos
frais
aimer les femmes intelligentes est un
plaisir de pédéraste faut des bras
l'amour c'est l'infini est la portée des
caniches élise mois en rouge et noir
j'exigerai mapper j'irai plus haut que
c'est bon là on va voir à faire l'amour
sur des malentendus on vit toujours des
moments défend de lewy marc lavoie c'est
bien le sexe mènent à la violence ou l
mélancolie ouais enfin c'est tellement
c'était ce que j'ai moi même a dit oui
non c'est assez bête en somme est pas
peu importe peut-être quelqu'un de très
bien qui a dit faire mais c'est assez
bête philippe sollers
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
a mende et mme hanoune a
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant celui qui a donné
pour titre au prochain numéro de son
magazine le par a voici pierre assouline
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
bonsoir pierre assouline vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction de l'excellent
magazine lire vous avez fait des
biographies biographie de dassault de
gallimard de jean jardin de simenon
berges et de cartier-bresson des
enquêtes sur combelles sur camondo des
romans et le dernier chez gallimard et
s'appelle double vie avant d'aborder le
cas sollers on va parler du cas
houellebecq puisque c'est lire en
septembre dernier qui a déclenché la
faire avec une interview de michel
houellebecq où il disait l'islam est la
religion la plus con leur métier au
tribunal cette semaine les rues line
vous aussi d'ailleurs je vous ai vue est
alors houellebecq a dit que dans
l'interview de lire dont il est question
ces propos avaient été tronquées ce qui
est faux évidemment l'interview n'a pas
été tronquée ça fait 27 ans que ce
journal existe évidemment il n'a jamais
eu un seul problème à akokan aucun
interviewé aucun écrivain et philippe
sollers peut en témoigner puisqu'il a
souvent fait la couverture de ce journal
il souvent répondu à des interviews et
toute façon il y avait des cassettes qui
était là était celle de l'enregistrement
qui ont prouvé la transcription
d'approuver que ça n'a évidemment pas
été truqué ça s'est passé comment
l'audience moi j'ai trouvé sollers
excellent oui cela c'est non plus sur
cet excellent jeu qui n'a pas été le cas
de oui les témoins il a été lady quoi
par exemple je veux dire donc celle
d'hier est quand même de 13h 30 à 23
heures
ça a été très violent très violent très
brutal très tendu parfois drôle grâce un
philippe et grâce à arrabal qui ont fait
les témoignages à la fois drôle et
intéressant et plus en plus il a eu du
passage qu'il est là mais il a été très
élégant
thierry ardisson avez vous déjà été
témoin dans un procès à la dix septième
chambre correctionnelle fait avec mais
fort j'ai même été inculpé bien
avez-vous déjà vu
suffit donc l'isolément des témoins
n'ont pas été inculpés alors je vais
vous dire comment la république
française aujourd'hui procède avec ces
témoins cette interdiction mis dans une
salle où ils n'ont pas le droit dont ils
n'ont pas le droit de sortir sans
boisson est aussi fois alors moi j'ai
attendu cinq heures ou pas c'est que
vous êtes enfermé à clef et si vous avez
envie de pisser vous êtes obligé de
demander la permission d'un gendarme en
le frappant à la porte qui vous
accompagnent jusqu'aux toilettes parce
que vous êtes censés ne pas avoir la
moindre communication avec l'extérieur
pendant que l'audience continue ce qui
est tout à fait visible puisque j'avais
mon portable dans ma poche et que
j'aurai vu en effet communiquer à
n'importe qui même avec n'importe qui me
faire donner des nouvelles de l'audience
et même parlé sur une radio que moi vous
même à la télévision en duplex
ce qui ne vous dit pas c'est que dans ce
beau cadeau c'est un beau cas là on
était enfermé dans plusieurs des cécités
- donc c'était vraiment six personnages
en quête d'auteur nos vraies pièces de
théâtre et arrabal n'arrêtait pas de
deux films seront gelées pendant ils
sont à l'enjeu produire mire et chacun
jouait son rôle c'est assez drôle et et
philippe brault clos il a il a pris
ainsi parlait zarathoustra qu'il avait
en poche et il nous l'a lu avec l'accent
de françois mitterrand et j'étais très
près de moi dites moi alors pourquoi en
couverture du prochain numéro de lire
qui sort le 27 septembre
c'est pourquoi vous marquez le parrain
manche et ils y sont discutés les fans
ces moments cruciaux doyon non sélective
à les plus connus mais surtout ce qui
est intéressant c'est que dès qu'il s'en
défende exerce une véritable influence
parce qu'il est au carrefour de
d'institutions soit dans la presse soit
dans l'édition prépare donc à me les
partis ou les chez gallimard il est
urgent même le nom il est en grosse
influence sur le monde des livres
mais vous dites quand même si c'était
moi qu'il faisait vraiment ça serait
meilleure ce qui est très gentil pour
josiane alain vigneault vous êtes au
journal du dimanche et à la radio ou
chez moi plus les romans bd réseau
comment ça se passe le logisticien le
solaire c'est un homme d'affluence mais
en même temps c'est pas quelqu'un enfin
moi je le vois pas comme ça comme
quelqu'un de machiavélique
c'est pas quelqu'un qu'on imagine qu'ils
tirent les ficelles toute façon entérite
de façon quoi qu'on dise sur l'homme
d'affluence sur le parrain et c'est le
roi des pirouettes
est-ce que avec tout ce qu'il a déclaré
depuis 40 ans sur la chine sur balladur
sur la france moisie sur le catholicisme
à tous les gens qu'il a défendus se sont
plantés sévriens d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que je vais vous défendre bientôt je
suis en plus blanc non mais c'est vrai
balladur je soumets mais c'est qu'elle a
du loft mais c'est ce qu'on avait
défendu 15 heures mais n'a plus jamais
entendu parler alors que steve hill et
là tous les jours j'aime j'aime les
pères dans son oeuvre restera vous
croyez bon ça on peut poser la question
sur n'importe quel écrivain n'y a pas de
réponse
moi personnellement je préfère ces
critiques à ses romans je mets femme à
part parce que je trouve que femme avec
le parquet le premier a été réussi mais
après ça m'intéresse beaucoup moins et
je trouve que ces critiques reviennent à
la guerre du goût sont beaucoup plus
intéressantes 1 et bonsu c'est ce qui se
relie le plus agréablement dix ans après
ce bouquin vous en pensez-quoi l'étoile
des amis des amants bas j'ai plus de
sympathie pour le l'auteur que pour le
roman si donc si ça va pas toucher
jamais laissé indifférent mais pourquoi
parce qu'il n'y a pas suscité tous les
sens s'est passé plein de citations je
sors du ressort de la lecture d'un roman
qui m'a fessier est très facile philippe
sollers qui sur le roman de philip roth
c'est ce que j'aime dans un roman c'est
cette vie c'est ça paraît pages de 140
rue ridge vous n'avez dit il est bon les
atomes il est partout non mais parce
qu'il va croissant ça ça me touche
beaucoup plus parce que c'est leur
montrer que je laime là c'est réservé
dimanche et 30 tombes des yeux d'enfants
alors vous vous posez la question dans
votre dans votre journal vous vous
demandez si philippe sollers et est un
prédateur des livres des autres ou un
bourreau de travail quelle est la
réponse que vous apportez moi ce qui me
frappe dans l' enquête il convainquait
de comptes publics dans le prochain
numéro
c'est que la plupart des amis de
philippe sollers que notre enquêtrice
marie gobain a interrogés disent tous là
philippe sollers
n'oubliez pas une chose il travaille
énormément contrairement à une idée
reçue travaille beaucoup et ça me
rappelle je disais c'est embêtant ça
fait sa banlieue ça me rappelle qu'on
regrette que j'ai dit ça
pour le reste c'est vrai que toute façon
quoi que vous disiez de philippe sollers
qui compte pour lui c'est qu'on parle du
oui et là où il est très fort ce verre
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est pour ou
contre sollers n'a toujours sollers au
milieu voilà c'est c'est l'écrivain
incontournable moi je la passe et
l'écrivaine permanence pierre ne trouvez
pas qu'il ressemble un peu à hervé bazin
actionnaire sétois des amants c'est chez
gallimard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez les bouquins d'assouline
j'ai eu la chance de faire partie du
jury du festival de paris
ouais et anouk aimée avait adoré son son
livre on avait plusieurs livres mais la
concurrence était forte parce qu'elle
met un boy avec un et double vie c'est
vraiment un bouquin mais passionnant un
film comme dans le style basique in
sting avec une feinte suspense
formidable et l'autre livre aussi le
précédent la cliente est un livre on
dirai pas quand on le voit comme ça w ah
oui et maintenant sur les coûts noir de
ma nuit blanche où je me fais du cinéma
ouais si elisabeth cas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va ça lui m sa valise aux bêtes et
chérie elisabeth quin critique cinéma à
elle arrive droite rive gauche sur paris
première
ah d'accord alors tout de suite on va
passer un mail de téléspectateurs
puisque vous savez que maintenant vous
pouvez poser des questions à nos invités
et la liste est une semaine avant sur le
site france2 tout le monde en parle
alors il s'appelle laurent bitton de
paris et il dit nous sommes très heureux
d'être informés grâce à vous sur les
derniers films chinois ou coréen sous
titré en bulgare mais n'avez-vous pas la
pression finalement de mépriser la
culture populaire mais non toutes les
cultures cohabitent bas existe bord tels
cas de les dire c'est le cas de la dia
bien la bi ton donc c'est quand même
assez stérile comme boulot critique de
cinéma terril
oui oui la preuve j'ai écrit un livre
partir de cette stérilité peut-être
entrer dans une autre vous allez me le
dire je m'attendais tomber sur d'autres
critiques enfin par mois parce que c'est
pas mon boulot mais alors vous avez
longtemps hésité en fait c'est vrai
entre les livres et le cinéma non étant
enfant vous a pas eu la vocation étant
enfant j'étais une enfant timide
tourmenté solitaire moche mal dans sa
peau et les livres - peut sauver la vie
ouais voilà la lecture la littérature
m'a sauvé la vie donc je lui ai rendu
peut-être mal j'en sais rien mais
j'avais oui voilà j'avais l'écriture
mais une chose importante 0 début sur
ouï fm vous parliez n'ont pas de cinéma
mais de littérature elle revoyait
absolument et puis un jour voilà le
responsable de la chronique cinéma n'est
pas venu et puis ça a été vous puis
après il ya eu nos vaillants rdr je
trouve oui c'est vrai avec lamo forlani
et puis vous êtes passé delà de la radio
à la télévision c'était pas évident au
début un magnéto faire la vie et
l'oeuvre de luc moullet pourrait se
résumer en une formule le farfelu tisme
intellectuelle il a été pendant
longtemps depuis trente ans un des gens
chaîne la vie et l'oeuvre de luc moullet
pourrait se résumer en une formule
j'enchaîne formule c'est enfin un
réalisateur qui a commis quelques vins
partie regarde pas ça m'énerve c'est bon
ça tourne
la vie et l'oeuvre de luc moullet
peuvent se résumer en une formule le
fort foutisme intellectuelle s'est sali
ses trouvailles visuelles ces merdes
j'enchaîne les parisiens vont pouvoir se
régaler à partir du 15 septembre avec
l'intégrale sacha guitry à la
cinémathèque avant goût la semaine
prochaine c'est pas ça que je dis dès
mardi
j'enchaîne elisabeth alors elizabeth
voilà la place maintenant ça mettait les
autres d'habitude ça n'est pas brillant
brillant faire le pitch kéké 35 ans
moitié française moitié chinoise mais
très parisienne agent d'acteurs de
cinéma qui un matin dans le métro
croiser le regard de gustave dit but il
a je vais lire deux pages
je sais bien c'est écrit gros d'image à
la fin du siècle dernier je demander en
mariage l'homme que j'étais en train de
chevaucher je connaissais gustave depuis
peu j'avais besoin de lui comme de mon
propre sang je ne savais pas encore que
je lui voulait du mal
un an plus tard gustave en eut assez que
je le tue à petit feu et que je la tâche
à un piquet face à un bol et une écuelle
fraîchement remplit tous les matins
tandis que ge allait augmenter mon
plaisir de ci de là le coeur inquiet et
les pattes arrières exténué par ce va et
vient entre piqué et proies car je ne me
sentais bien qu'à 3 ni bonnes ni
méchante j'étais avant tout une vieille
enfants au bois dormant qui attendaient
depuis des siècles le baiser d armand ma
revendication est est simple être matée
terrassé par un maître indiscutable je
voulais être prises tremblay de joie au
pied de mon seigneur et ne plus jamais
souhaité d'autres places
faute de quoi je continuerai à faire
tourner les
au dessus de mon doigt et à leur couper
les couilles pour en revenir à gustave
il ressuscita d'entre les éventrer émane
ministre à un formidable coup je n'avais
pas fini de déguster pas mal c'est pas
très féministes c'est pas c'est le moins
qu'on puisse en dire mais c'est assez
juste
et c'était assez bien écrit c'est de
l'histoire d'un trio une histoire de huy
d'infidélité vécue par une femme qui se
retrouve dans une situation plutôt
incongru c'est à dire qu'elle est elle
un amant et au fond plutôt que d'être
dans les bras de son mari et de penser à
son amant et bien et dans les bras de
son amant et c'est seulement dans les
bras de cet amant qu'elle peut penser à
cet homme qu'elle aime qui est son mari
voilà pourquoi at elle besoin d'
instrumentaliser un troisième type
pauvre mec n'a rien demandé voilà et
c'est l'histoire d'une fille qui
rencontre un homme qui l'épousé qui
précipite le couple ouais à sa chute
c'est dommage parce que début ça va bien
quand elle rencontre guc et toux sèche à
lundi une meilleure amie avec un pénis
oui c'est ça il manquait quelque chose
donc un qui est assez bête est amoureux
si elle vit ça bouge faisait éclore des
anémones de mer dans mon ventre mais
vous n'avez jamais été lyrique quand
vous étiez amoureux mais bien sûr on se
doit et moi aussi j'ai fait éclore des
anémones 2 allait bien à 4 donc ils vont
aux caraïbes avec du style elle le
trompe effectivement hippiques et le
retour ou louer pour pourquoi pour
vérifier c'est juste une fille une fille
qui est un peu bébête comme vous dites
mais c'est une fille qui quand on est
deux nist une jouisseuse qui aime la vie
en même temps qu'ils souffrent d'être
dans cette situation pénible où elle a
besoin de tester l'amour de l'autre
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas assez dur d
mais c'est dur d mais quand on n'a pas
confiance en soi et c'est dur d'accepter
qu'on vous aime
voilà et elle est confronté à ça c'est
une fille qui a envie de fusion et qui
est insatisfaite c'est un trou sans fond
c'est un gouffre c'est un abîme voilà
elle voudrait qu'on la comble alors elle
a besoin de preuves toutes plus
impossibles les unes que les autres
une fille d'aujourd'hui et elle ajoute
mentir et tromper
tu es ma seconde nature et peut-être ma
vraie nature
c'est beau elle elle veut tester qui
sont à nos son mari c'est à dire alors
elle va exprès avec canal pour tester
son mari oui alors ya les mêmes et qu'on
lui pardonne mais là à quel moment elle
ce test elle même mais tout le temps de
l'aimer tous enfin c'est ça les femmes
d'accord et oui je vais l'acheter
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire le seul truc c'est que elle
trompe ce fameux qu avec un
quinquagénaire est ce quinquagénaire
écoutez bien francis huster la
transforme en tchat
obscène ondulant cul à l'air pur
connaissez bien la façon de faire des
quinquagénaires n'est qu'un cas j'aime
j'en suis sûr vous avez un début de
réaction aiguë lui dit aiguë de lui dit
vous êtes fidèles à tuer fidèles comme
un hôtel de passe dès que les femmes
parlent de sexualité et s'acharnant
débridé comme ça ça vous fâchez pas se
bouffer sauf un drôle d'effet non
seulement un coup c'est ça qui vous fait
bouger les couilles le truc l'aja n'en
commet tous ceux meilleurs pasaia part
ça j'ai dit il ya d'abord quelqu'un qui
a énormément d'autodérision et d'idées
et pas mal d'humour sur elle même façon
elle a plus que ça dans sa vie est un
désastre total elle n'a plus que ça pour
se rapprocher espèces debout et en sucre
qui font petit à petit son humour son
autodérision et puis il ya la souffrance
quoi il ya quand même la souffrance de
faire mal à l'autre
on dit toujours on souffre quand on les
travaille et celui qui trahit soulève un
nombre inférieur aux histoires au
sérieux pas au sérieux a voulu d'un
diplomate avec moi je lui dis que c'est
bien écrit que marc berthod voulez quand
même pas que la souffrance de keke sanou
la pire dans le monde a franchement bien
vous avez continué à écrire
eh bien oui mais oui j'ai déjà écrit le
deuxième de 1000 pages trois volumes oui
jamais qs lui doit plus rien à quoi rien
je vais venir en touriste de l'accueil
l'accueil est bon jusqu'à maintenant
cela n'a cueilli
et perfide certains il plutôt bon vous
aviez dit dans le nouvel observateur une
dinde de télé qui explique d'écriture ça
va agacer donc fausses alertes n'avaient
pas lu encore si j'ai très bien dans
l'au delà et la première page est
épatant ouais c'est bien ce que gêné de
pierre attention très bonnes critiques
taurine rue de valmy tic dans
l'excellent trimer plus très mauvaises
critiques dans les inrocks
oui mais ce sont des garnements est
guéri et je pense que la critique n'est
pas motivée par des raisons littéraire
mais par d'autres raisons donc ça n'a
aucune importance
elisabeth qu'à la peau dure c'est chez
grasset
[Musique]
m
et à celui de jours laissait filer merci
d'être venus et puis donc lisez le
bouquin d'elisabeth c'est pas mal moi je
les ai vus j'ai bien aimé a bien été au
pierre nagy beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant
j'accueille jean luc lemoine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir jean luc lemoine vous reprenez
votre one man show à la comédie
caumartin jean luc lemoine est
inquiétant nous en avons parlé ici lors
de la saison dernière on regarde
aquasar son magnéto serge intelligente
oui au vu pourquoi pas
non je suis c'est important
l'intelligence matou choisir je préfère
une femme ou alors qu'il est
l'intelligence de la cuisine et voilà
qu'ils comprennent comment fonctionnent
les appareils ménagers
mais parce que moi j'ai essayé de
m'intéresser j'y comprends rien mais
c'est là on se dit que c'est bien pensé
ces trucs là ils savent à qui
s'adressent les prenez un aspirateur une
femme ça la passionne elle joue avec
dans toute la maison très important
aussi je voudrais une femme qui n'aime
pas les préliminaires
alors je trouve que c'est une perte de
temps ou alors qu'il fait les
préliminaires tout seul
[Rires]
autonome j'en ai de moelle et inquiétant
à la comédie caumartin
alors jean luc lemoine on va vous faire
une anti interview alors ralenti
interview c'est très simple je vous
donne les réponses et vous me donnez les
questions par exemple bien et vous
comment faites-vous l'amour
[Rires]
par exemple inquiétant mais pas méchant
c'est l'abus sais pas comment trouvez
vous tiriez ardisson on continue chantal
lauby
comment s'appelle votre ancien metteur
en scène remplacé aujourd'hui par
marie-pascale osterrieth a du mal à le
dire encore je dis pas je vais juste à
c'était la metteuse de dames - michel on
continue café théâtre
comment s'appelle une salle de spectacle
coup quand vous êtes assis vous avez les
genoux dans mon père stevie du lot
dans votre vie quelle est la personne
qui vous a le plus influencé
[Rires]
toujours les réponses
virginie lemoine si vous aviez dû
choisir un pseudo comment vous seriez
vous appeler parce que cela ne nous
regarde pas pourquoi vous ne voulez pas
qu'on parle de votre liaison et kevin
leclerc non ok quelle est la personne
sans qui vous seriez encore vendeurs de
kebabs
on a tout essayé
comment s'appellent les missions qui a
reçu le prix nobel de la meilleure
mission de la terre humour noir
pourquoi dites vous dans votre spectacle
qu'un enfant dépressif et un enfant
calme
acné à l'adolescence comment s'appelle
votre compagne
[Rires]
à
oh ben oui vous les jeux mass le dos
[Rires]
franchement ça me ferait mal au cul est
ce que ça vous dirait de passer un mois
sur une île déserte avec dave
jamais par là non êtes vous déjà allé à
melun par la départementale 32
[Rires]
je ne sais pas pourquoi gérard miller
s'obstina mais des t-shirts trop petit
qui hume ou son corps chétif à l'âge de
12 ans
[Rires]
quand avez-vous marché pour la première
fois connais pas qu'est ce que vous
pensez du dernier single de jean pascal
[Applaudissements]
jean luc lemoine la comédie chorale
d'argent et maintenant on va maintenant
passer au blind faith la phase terminale
de cette émission et pour participer aux
blindes tel j'appelle le grand champion
pascal sellem
[Musique]
alors ce soir c'est un blind test
spécial collection est aux platines
j'appelle attention moi je vais me
garder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le blind test
[Musique]
attention attention se concentre alors
on va jouer ce soir par équipes
le thème c'est les collections en
hommage à inès de la fressange bien
entendu et donc on joue par équipe donc
joui des métiers du fer dans l'équipe on
and on reste calme et la saône à 30 ans
à pascal séailles c'est un génie absolu
aux blindes thèse mais le député kolélas
juteau vire l'interprète l'interprète
j'aurais pas d'accord haïssent
attention quand même à se rabaisser
attention fipa
[Musique]
l'interprète
[Applaudissements]
je préviens le public quand carine
soufflage je fais évacuer la salle
attention ferme
je suis capable de tout
[Applaudissements]
à
je sais je suis capable de tout
attention philippe débat
c'est un mystère
[Applaudissements]
attendez replay finit pas d'épater
on tient à donner le petit catherine
barma me dis à l'insee
alice evans attention cependant ces
chiens
[Applaudissements]
oh
quelques poids pour ce défi et un point
pour cette équipe là donc c'est ça alice
et 22 points pascal sellem un point
attention philippe passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sinatra la chanson de lissage all good
way lycée louis dont concert à paris
d'ailleurs attention philippe pain c'est
parti
[Musique]
ils l'ont fait les comptes par équipe de
4 pour l'équipe des trucs
à toi attention philippe piat heures tu
la téléphonie
[Applaudissements]
attention pipe google
[Musique]
il ya là là là là on est à 4 4 4 pour
les truffes et quatre équipages francis
huster le ronaldinho de la musique et
philippe
[Musique]
ça faisait deux petits mois de l'état
[Applaudissements]
je vous écoute et souvent d'une balle
dans le dos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en étais blablatage du seul dernier
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
passion française est justement là où il
est très fort c'est qui c'est que c'est
un blind test sur la mode et les
connexions et comme topalov a fait la
chemise gris
cela fait 6 po et en mai
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bien
j'en ai fait moi les stray cats
pichenette stocking
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'ennemi berramla messieurs
absolument attention fip c'est pour toi
tant la série en était un
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant nous arrivons au banco aïe
aïe aïe le gagnant du banco va remporter
le match mais pourquoi tu ris parce que
la beauté du jeu devant la prison
claustration pour le banc coude s'il
vous plaît je veux l'interprète fini
[Musique]
nancy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non non non parce qu après le bon coup
il ya le super bon beurre
simple qui va remporter le super banco
remportera ce match
attention film
où sont passées
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
oui
incroyable incroyable bravo philippe
sollers excellente
c'est jean constantin croyez moi il
était tout moment par l'émission qui
n'est pour rien dans la libération
demain
espérons avec ap samad moussaoui
zacarias moussaoui
mon frère j'ai de noël à pâques
francis huster merci j'ai dernier merci
on vous retrouve d'ennui vibrer de érige
en scène par julien benneteau à la
renaissance
c'est à partir du baltringue septembre
olivier besancenot
merci
jean pierre gaillard de lci de france à
bout de france inter inès de la
fressange et les martys profession même
gars chez hachette littératures du
solaire si le gagnant noblesse écrit les
toiles des amants chez gallimard
pierre assouline le directeur de la
rédaction du magazine me
elisabeth cac et subit la peau du rejet
grasset maire
là
merci la partie avec maurice jean marie
poiré
les galiciens régis être à l'aise
chevalier martin lamotte anémone jean
lemoine épinoches en sortie le 25
septembre jean-luc lemoine jean luc
lemoine est inquiétant alan comédie
caumartin et le libéria d'artisanat
reprend pour la liberté de la presse au
profit de reporter sans frontières voilà
c'était souvent par ce rendez vous la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]
je
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]